everybody my name is Martin I'm from
Switzerland and I love to be here I'm
super excited to see you all and it's
gonna be a great great time there's one
thing that is not an official
administrative thing that's something
that I just care about a lot which is I
do this workshop for you it's not for me
right so if you have any questions or if
there's anything unclear or everything
not working it is my fault not yours so
please please please please tell me if
something is unclear or something
doesn't make sense or something doesn't
work because then we can fix it together
that's why I'm here for if you wouldn't
ask questions or like say something
doesn't work on my computer or something
like that then you could as well just
watch a youtube video or something so I
think the it makes the most sense to
just you know talk to me when there's
something wrong that's what I'm here for
or at least I hope that that's what I'm
here for robots won't replace me anytime
soon hopefully we have a Wi-Fi if you
haven't seen that already there's like a
shangri-la Wi-Fi that should not require
a password and it should work TM I have
a fallback solution in case things are
not working but it's gonna be a little
inconvenient to set that all up so I'd
rather try let's let's try Wi-Fi if that
doesn't work then we can still fall back
anytime else like anyone having problems
connecting to the Wi-Fi no good if so
let me know if the Wi-Fi dies for you
during the workshop let me know as well
and I'll share the files with you in a
different way and then we can just you
know have it all work also if things
should go horribly wrong I can always
ask the organizers to help us out
because they promise they have a
fallback solution which I definitely
think they will have because they're
well organized here which is nice
regarding the details there's going to
be lunch at 12:30 it's gonna be
basically it's it's not as centralized
as they wanted it to be apparently so we
have two lunch spots one is two floors
down on three if you go that direction
you see like dine on three or something
like that and if you go around the
corner there's like a buffett restaurant
it's called the silver shell cafe
alternatively if you were more a fan of
sitting at the beachfront
of beach from the seafront more or less
you can also go completely down to floor
one and then go in that direction and
that's something that's called barnacles
by the sea I think that's probably gonna
be a seafood restaurant so that's not
gonna be where I am being they also have
a different Wi-Fi ad the barnacles by
the sea buildings so if you are having
lunch over there and need a Wi-Fi
connection and shangri-la should not
work there's also the jeaious con asia
network with the beware of the cat's
password so lunch is gonna be at 12:30
you have drinks here should you feel
thirsty then just get up and get a drink
we're not in a classical classroom
setting 5:30 p.m.
so 5:30 in the afternoon there's gonna
be a group photo at the beach the beach
is pretty large so I'm not exactly sure
where that's gonna be but I guess we're
gonna work that one out
and then 5:45 after the group photo
that's gonna be dinner at the beach as
well yes so toilets are available here
on this floor as well as on every other
floor so that shouldn't be a problem
yeah there's like we have been whoops
that we have been promised snacks
between 10:00 and 11:00 so let's see if
that's helping but as I said like if you
want some water or some coffee just grab
one any time the coffee maybe only when
I'm like having you all figure out
something because it's kind of is loud
so it's not like the best thing I can
talk over it I can be louder than a
coffee machine but I'd rather not have
to be cool so if you have a full-day
workshop you would be able to leave your
stuff here but I highly recommend taking
your things with you for lunch because
I'm a not sure whether where the next
workshop is going to be is like if it's
in the same room I don't know but also
it's not guaranteed to like be locked up
and stuff so just take your things with
you during lunch and then bring them
back when you come back cool all right
so I would say let's start um I know
that a few people are like doing slides
and presentations and stuff but I am
like no we are here for workshop so
let's do things together
and and I would suggest that we that we
get going like this so shut the Wi-Fi
not die and I really really hope it
doesn't then you should be able to go to
the following URL it should be I gonna I
go to make that large in a second just
give me a moment
the a-frame workshop so if you go to
this URL and I can make that even larger
no I can't okay fair enough
Jesus this is annoying ah this is better
so this wonderful URL should take you to
a Gillett what's called a glitch a
glitch is nothing like magical or fancy
it's just a way to have like a really
really easy setup in the browser it's
basically just serving static files and
that's like convenient because we don't
have to set anything up we don't have to
run any software on your computer you
can just start with what is there anyone
not having this URL typed in already
bear in mind I have put taking it from
my brain so it might actually not lead
you to where I think it leads you so let
me let me double check it's the right
URL yes yes so if okay right that was
not the best idea that I had if I go
here I should see something like this
right so if you click on remix your own
you should see tintin tintin tintin
tintin tintin yes this now this is not
very exciting and it's like the standard
placeholder thing but the interesting
thing is happening in index.html so we
want to have a look at index.html
probably by the way if you cannot read
this let me know and I can make that
larger is that readable people in the
back row give me a thumbs up or thumbs
down good okay good as I say like this
is for you not for me if you have
anything or anything is not making any
sense then let me know so I basically
set you up with some things that I just
think makes sense like ignore all this
crap here this is like boilerplate stuff
in the first couple of rows no one cares
this is the more interesting things we
are loading a few libraries let's
actually comment out the second one and
the third one for a moment so I'm going
to remove these two scripts and that's
just lower a frame
and actually I don't know why this is
still here let's remove the class hidden
as well I don't think it does anything
but let's remove it just for shits and
giggles so this is basically like a
boring old website so if I put in an h1
tag and say like hello.js Khan's Asia
and then an h2 tag like how's it hanging
and then we click on the little show
life button a new tab should open with
our beautiful website which is like
probably the best website I've ever done
and the projector is cutting something
off I think but okay that's not a
problem you know it's not that exciting
so we have just like a normal HTML page
but because we have this particular
thing here that's called a scene we have
some special magical powers actually
let's not remove that let's go in here
and if you press ctrl alt I and that's
control on a MacBook keyboard it's not
command it's control all I you should
see this ha curious isn't it does that
work for everyone does it not work for
you Oh a that's interesting hmm
anyone else who's not having this on
screen yeah it should be ctrl alt I or
control option I control option I nope
okay well then let's let's wait with
that just like so this this is basically
a hint that I want to give you there
something going on under the surface and
we're gonna see what this is in a second
let's go back to our HTML so I'm gonna
remove all this crap for a second and
we're just gonna go in here now what is
this a scene well for VRA our and just
generally 3d content on the web we need
a way to actually express what we're
gonna do and there's a few metaphors
right so for instance if you think about
it the web site it's not a web page it's
not actually a page it's not a page in a
physical book it's not something that
you can take into your hand so while we
are using the page abstraction of the
page metaphor to work with like 2d
content we are working on a frame
decided to work with the scene metaphor
for 3d continent basically what it is
about is so
would you how will you design or Express
3d content in a way like how do you talk
about it and the easiest way to talk
about it is basically staging a theater
play or staging a movie so we have a
scene which is an empty space somewhere
so this could be my scene and then we
have objects like me
yes I checked in myself today so
basically you have objects that you put
in and you can move them around and you
can make them do things and you can you
know combine them like or even like I
can move this thing around this is an
object as well or an entity in this case
and I can maybe like rotate it that was
not the best idea there's a physic
engineer at play here so yeah I can
rotate the objects that I have I can
well I can't in the real world but I
could scale them up I could make them
larger or smaller and I can move them
around in space so this is kind of like
the thinking metaphor that we've got and
there's actually two more things what do
you also need when you do a movie so I
have a scene and I have like actors and
objects and props and stuff right well
making a movie is pretty hard when you
don't have a camera so we have to have a
camera we have to have a scene and we
have to have objects that we are going
to film also if this is a closed room
it's not going to look very fancy if
there's no light so we also need light
now conveniently here we have some
lights of the slides shining on me this
light is shining on me and I'm an object
on my scene these objects in a CA frame
are called entities it's just a
terminology sometimes other libraries
call them differently very populous also
to call them meshes
sometimes they are called objects but
for the sake of a frame we're calling
them entities so a frame by the way is a
library from Mozilla like super cool
stuff and it's making things much much
easier than they used to be I can show
you how it look like before we're doing
if I'm like we're gonna do some FM and
then I'll show you how it looks like
when you're not having a frame available
and you're gonna see why we're doing it
in a frame so our a scene is basically
the exactly this is empty space there's
nothing in here okay so now how can we
fill that with something well as I said
we have to put in entities which are our
objects so let's do that and a frame
wraps everything in these custom HTML
elements which is like so
nice so you can say entity and then we
have an object in our scene but if you
like me and would now reload you would
see nothing well that's unfortunate huh
and the reason why is that an object
itself does not does not resemble
anything it's not visible it's basically
just a point in space an invisible point
in space you don't see anything because
it's not looking like anything so what
you want to do is you want to add
something to it that actually makes it
look like something well how can we do
that well a friend does what's called
the entity component model it's a
basically a way of doing things and
organizing your code with that game
engines usually use and so we now have
to add a component and how do you add a
component well conveniently it's just an
attribute to our HTML tag so we're gonna
start with we want to have something
that looks like something so we probably
want to start with geometry because we
want to need some you know we're gonna
need a shape so let's give it a shape
let's say geometry and and these
components can have good morning oh I'm
sorry was it not oh all right
you didn't miss out too much yet so take
a seat we're gonna catch you up real
quick
so I was explaining that you want to
start with the following URL and I'm
gonna show you the URL real quick and
from there on you gonna go like remix
and then you can catch up sorry for that
we're just gonna put in a moment's time
by the way is anyone not having like
working Wi-Fi on their computer right
now and not having this working well if
they enough yet you two excluded because
you're literally just setting up
[Applause]
yeah the shangri-la Wi-Fi should not
require a password and seems to be
working
all right you're both on the on the
website you're both having the remix
button there remix remix your own is the
button that you want to have for this
holy crap by I'm gonna sing anything
are you caught up as well okay perfect
wonderful so you click on the remix your
own thing and then you should be oh i'm
not signed in okay I'm okay with that
got it if I lose it I lose it that's
what happens like living on the edge so
what we also did is we commented out the
last two scripts because we're not gonna
need them right now and we removed the
class hidden from the a scene there
there was a class on here we remove that
as well because we're gonna be only use
it later on so yeah so as I explained
everything is an entity but identity
doesn't look like anything by default so
we have to add this geometry component
and it's kind of nice that we don't like
make up countries because in 3d graphics
everything is made from triangles so we
would have to now figure out like all
the triangles all over the place so
instead of doing that what we can do is
we can use a primitive which is
basically built in simple geometries
that we can use for instance we can say
primitive box which is going to give us
all the points and connections between
the points to form a box
okay that's lovely and however we're not
gonna still not gonna see that by the
way what we are looking at here is
basically so this is the entity this is
a component and components can have
multiple parameters right so one of
these parameters is which primitive we
want to pick and it looks a little like
Jason without the quotes so we could
also do like I don't know ASD however
like full bar or something like that we
can even do like bars and then give it
an array of things now obviously all
these attributes are not known to the
component so we're just going to remove
them I'm just wanted to show you that
all these kind of things are possible so
we start with a primitive box but now
what color do you think the box will
have how does it look like any guesses
okay transparent is one guess I know
nothing
well what's what color is nothing and
white white is a good choice so
the thing we don't know because a frame
tries to not you know screw us over so
it's gonna pick a color at random which
is nice like this is actually nice
because you know it tries to do its
thing
oftentimes it's white but it's not
always white and it's like can be like
super confusing so to fix that we're
just gonna give it a material so this is
another component right we're following
the same pattern here it's a component
and this one has parameters as well so
the first thing I probably want to
figure out is like what's the color so
we can make this red and this is nice it
supports a bunch of actual color names
it doesn't support all the CSS colors I
think but it supports like most of them
so we can use a color name but we can
also say 0x ff0000
so that works actually no sorry no
that's actually not them no no no ff0000
like we are used to from HTML and CSS
but I'm gonna stick with red for for the
sake of simplicity for the moment and
now what happens now let's see let's
reload oh nothing what did we do wrong
oh my god now now try to get the try to
get the key command that I did earlier
on so like click on something somewhere
here and then go control option I or
control alt I and you should see this
does that it doesn't still doesn't work
what the heck see this is the fun thing
this is I love it when it doesn't work
because you know that's what I'm here
for
yes I'm worth my money than I doesn't do
anything that's like really weird that's
like a weird thing why is it not doing
this
a frame we should be fine it should be
lonely frickin thing but it's not
ha-ah
this is a fun one no that's okay well
fair enough but hmm there's no arrows
here so I'm not exactly sure why is that
this is a fun one do you I don't think
so but we can try it so in that that's
one of the cases wait anyone else not
seeing this particular screen there's a
few people all right so I'll I've never
seen that before so I'm excited to
figure out what else we can do to get
this working so I'll really quick so by
the way this is like if you ever have a
problem with a frame this is like all
you want to be yeah this has all the
information and all the links to
communities and github issues and stuff
so what we're going to do is I'm going
to try to figure out if there's another
way to get the inspector up and running
because what we are seeing here these
are like to build in developer tools for
a frame and they are super handy so I
know it says I control all I so I'm not
I'm not like jump or doing something
ridiculous mm-hmm this is not coming up
so that's an interesting one let's see
if they have help here somewhere because
I'm pretty sure there is a way to
programmatically call this alright time
to explore [ __ ] let's let's do something
it's not something that I've prepared
but you know this is the stuff I live
for it's like the adventures let's go on
an adventure let's get our a scene and
ask what components ups up okay fair
enough I saw that coming
[Applause]
so let's see dart components dot
inspector does this thing have something
that I can work with initialized is
playing true uh-huh what the hell right
let me reload this because you're not at
this point where the inspectors actually
loaded so let's try this
so without the inspector being loaded it
has the exact same details here mm-hmm
that's a weird one okay so it doesn't
seem to be having a method that I could
call unless it's not sure yeah sure let
me let me try something that's what
happens when I do this okay nothing
that's perfect what happens when I do
this nothing that's perfect what happens
when I do update no okay fair enough
let's try this one and does it have like
systems maybe
let's see no does not okay cool so the
inspector is a component which is nice
what kind of data does it have it only
has a URL so that's not really helpful
okay cool let's have a look at the
component in here because it must have
some sort of myth so this is actually
not part of the regular workshop but I
think we can squeeze this one in because
it's just going to be interesting to
have a look at how these things actually
work under the hood so let's have a look
so we do have no those are the widgets
so that's not gonna help us
oh maybe oh this is a react thing isn't
it
ah [ __ ] but it has to at some point
visible aha
well but that's not I don't think that's
that's helping toggle side part no
that's not what I want to do mmm-hmm
okay right I'm not exactly sure so let's
that's Google this inspect a frame
inspector without programmatically
program yeah
yeah
aha wait actually I have an idea that's
it that's a very good one and I think I
have an idea actually let me give me a
second view so because a co-worker of
mine did this button that shows it so
maybe just maybe how does he do the
button ah look at that
so basically ahahahaha so instead of so
the people who have problems with the
key combination should probably be able
to do the following thing and let me
zoom in yeah so if you do like window
dot post message inject a frame
inspectors star that should apparently
trigger the inspector as well I'm very
sorry for that little detour window the
post message to inject a frame inspector
like this so this is woopsy where the
hell jay all right here we go this is
like the line that you want to go for
so if if that is the workaround you have
to do because the keyboard key
combination doesn't work then that's how
you so anyone in this work yeah it does
work so it does everyone have this
wonderful dev tools open now yes good if
not let me know because now is the time
to figure that one out so the nice thing
about the dev tools is they're like
super handy and they show something that
yes you don't write you needed this I
guess it's that the one you're looking
for
does it work for you if you do that in
the comments of the console you're
basically like you open the dev tools
and then in there you should run this
command and then it should give you the
works
look this thing is called bleeding edge
because it you cut yourself every now
and then so this is this is like the
cuts you get does everyone have the
inspector now or is there Excel still
someone not having the inspector open
everyone ready okay sweet so now again
so these dev tools are building into a
fem they're like super nice and they
show us something that we didn't know
because a frame is actually nice to us
so I said early on if we wanted if we
want to think about what we're doing in
terms of like 3d AR VR content in the
web we're basically making a movie so we
have an empty scene and we have a camera
and we have a light and then we have
objects which are called entities in a
frame now if you notice in our HTML we
have only added an entity but we do not
have any light or any camera right we
didn't do that but a frame is so nice
and saying like well look if you don't
have a camera you can't really have a
movie so people would be like super
annoyed by the fact that they are not
seeing anything so if you do not have
any light or camera we're gonna add that
for you
so a frame make sure that we always have
at least like one light and one camera
available so what you see here is like
this thing that looks like a bit weird
like a star with a wide thing coming
from it that's the camera so basically
we are standing here and looking in that
direction and everything within these
these lines these orange lines is what
we actually I'm not exactly sure
can I turn off the light in front of you
because I think it's really hard to see
isn't it let's see I don't know what's
gonna happen when I press on this
nothing that's awesome
nope nope I have no idea oh look at that
here we go
magically it did the thing probably
running java that's why the delay
to be anyway so you see like everything
in this box that looks like in this
direction
is visible everything else is outside of
our field of view and that kind of
mimics how humans like see we have this
like field of vision and we're seeing
like everything that is around here but
if I put something here or under me I'm
not actually seeing it so what we have
here is everything unless I give it an
explicit position is that zero zero zero
except for the camera which is a 1 meter
60 in the air and that's because it goes
like well okay in this case I have no
information how how tall the user is I
don't know how tall you are until you
tell me right so I'm assuming an adult
is probably like the average adult is
like one meter 60 so if I put your eyes
level on one meter 60 it kind of looks
like natural so it automatically moves
the camera up to one meter 60 above the
ground our box is at zero zero zero by
the way notice that the position that
something is is always the center of it
well not always but in this case it is
in the center so the center point here
in this box in the middle of the box is
at zero zero zero
the box is below us we're not seeing it
because we're on top of the box and also
this white thing here that's a light
that's a light shining from this
direction and you can see that it's
slightly brighter here than here and
that's because the lights coming from
this direction okay so we're not seeing
anything right now because we are on top
of the box but that means that if I use
and again a frame gives us this for free
if I drag with my mouse I should be well
why is it not showing okay whatever yeah
this is the day oh I'm looking upwards
now that was very smart Martin here we
go
there it is right below us you can use
WASD to actually move around as well
this is also like a default from a frame
so it gives you a reasonable default you
can move around and then you see like
the box here okay cool nice but if I
reload I have the same problem
I'm standing on top of it I'm not seeing
anything right so so what's nice is in
the in this developer tools it's not
just like a way to actually look into
the scene but it also gives us a little
bit of power so what happens if I click
on the box you see that now that I
clicked on the box a few things appear
first things first as
like this blue box around the box this
is called the bounding box and then you
have like this this bunch of things here
right so what happens when I press on
this oh look at that I can move it
around surprise surprise what happens if
i push this oh I can move it around so
we basically get a few controls that
allow us to move The Box around and if I
go back to scene
the box is now at the position where I
put it this is not the only thing that
we can do so if you look here up here
you see like there is there's a few
things up here right now
in blue is this one and that's because
we are in the moving mode so we can move
objects around like this but if we click
here we get a different cursor we get
this like weird lines around the object
so now what we can do is we can rotate
it around and you see that the box is
merely there to show us like where's the
where's the maximum distance from the
from the middle point of this thing so
basically like this is called a bounding
box because it always surrounds the
object as tightly as it can right
let me move zoom out again so here we
are at this moment right so in the like
wait you have the inspector open right
yes so up here in the inspector there
and I'm zooming in again we have these
three buttons and it allows you to
switch to rotation and it also allows
you to scale so you can also go and if i
zoom if i zoom out again you now have
different controls again yes like you
don't get the inspector wait did you
join us later or something or does this
ride okay so does the scene look like
this right now
do you have removed the class hidden
from AC because it was like this before
and I think there's a CSS that actually
then hides the scene so if you remove
that you should see the scene again and
well now I undid all my changes so I'm
just gonna quickly move things again
like here and then I rotate this a
little bit and now I can also scale it
in all directions I can scale it like
here and here and here or maybe not
oops uh maybe not like that uh okay that
was not the smartest plan I had to like
scale it like weirdly here we go and
then you have like the scene as you
presented it so this is a very visual
way of creating these things and this is
convenient because it gives you other
possibilities as well so first things
first you can also see the position
rotation and scale up here so if you in
the upper right hand corner you have the
current object that is selected you have
the information of position rotation and
scale here as well along the three axes
I think we haven't talked about the axis
system form for this moment so let's
actually try that out
so first axis is the x axis this is how
far to the left and to the right it is
in meters so one means it's one meter to
the left or to the right minus one means
one meter to the left from the from the
middle which is like this line here so I
can move that around like this or I can
put it at minus two meters and then it's
gonna be here I can also just enter the
scale here and then it's gonna scale
along the same three axes the rotation
is sometimes a bit confusing but if you
think about rotating around an axis you
can I like or I remember it like this so
we have the three axes we have the x
axis like this we have the y axis like
this and we have the z axis negative
values go sorry go into the screen
positive values go towards the screen so
if you want to think about how rotation
works and we rotate around an axis if I
rotate around the y axis so this is my
axis that I rotate around basically I
put like a skewer through me and then
we'll play like that right
if I rotate around the x-axis what's
gonna happen correct like this if I
rotate around the z axis I'm gonna do
like this weird
monkey movement so this is how rotation
works in the three axes and the axes are
kind of like always the same so they
follow the object wonderful the rotation
order as far as I'm aware is yxz
but I might be wrong it might be X Y Z
luckily that is normally hidden behind
the interface so yes okay cool great
there's also some more stuff down here
on the right hand side so what is there
for instance is the actually I'm gonna
just generally zoom in the page I think
what we also have here is like if it's
visible or not so we can hide this
object entirely by just clicking on it
you can also do the same thing here so
that's like a shortcut you also see all
the objects in the scene on the left
hand side but we're gonna look into that
in a second but we also see all the
components individually listed here so
this this box this entity here has like
a box geometry so like there's a
geometry with a primitive box nice and
it has a material that has a color of
red nice so basically all these
informations all the components are
always going to be listed here so what
we can do is we can also change things
in here which is like super nice so for
instance like a box is nice and fine and
I'm probably gonna reset like the the
orientation and the scale and I'm gonna
put it at like zero zero minus two so I
put it minus two meters
sorry yeah two meters into the screen so
that it's like in front of me actually
let's put that into code how do we do
that again position is a special kind of
component but it's a component and it
takes a position in X Y Z so they say
like nothing to the no meters to the
left or to the right no me just to up or
down and minus two meters so like minus
two meters out of the screen or two
meters into the screen the box by
default is one meter by one meter so
it's gonna be well in the screen right
now so if we reload we see like down
here and the fact that we have to look
down on it is because we are one meter
60 high right our eyes are not on the
ground so you could also if you want to
let's let's do that let's
looks a bit more boring but let's do
that we couldn't put it on one meter 60
y X Adam Y and then we have it like on a
level so this box is now on a level
wonderful but what we can do when we
select the box and go into the geometry
component we can change the primitive so
for instance we can use a cylinder or we
can use a dodecahedron whatever we can
use pretty much everything that 3GS
comes with and there's a bunch of them a
sphere a torus yeah let's have a donut a
torus not which is like the least useful
thing ever but it looks kind of fancy so
here we go yeah it's the pretzel of 3d
or the pile of poo depends a little bit
on the perspective so we can do that and
we can do that for all the components so
big a CV we can change like the the
parameters here which for the tourists
are not very intuitive for the material
it's a little easier so I can for
instance click on the color in the
material component and say I don't like
red I want this to be bluish like this
and maybe I want this to be I don't know
like super shiny so let's set that to
like one and then you get like the super
shiny torus not in blue or maybe you
want the wireframe you know optics so
now this looks more likely I don't know
90s things that you would see on screen
nice that's pretty good so you can
basically control everything in here but
now the problem is if I reload I lose
all that right and I don't want to type
everything out that I change down here
so that's like super annoying so I have
a bunch of possibilities to make that
easier for me one possibility is I can
just copy the attributes of one
individual component if I only made
changes to one of them but I didn't I
actually changed the entire component
like where it's positioned and
everything I can change that like this
maybe I want to move it over here and
then there's this button over here
that allows me to either download the
thing as an as a file or just copy it to
clipboard and that's what I'm gonna do
and copy this to clipboard and if I now
go back into my code and say okay I want
to put this in here then you see like it
puts all the things it's quite a bit but
it's it puts all the things into our
code I'm gonna make this a little more
readable by putting these below each
other so that it's nicer to actually
read this but this is nice because I no
longer have to like remember these
values I can just copy this around and
let's say if I if I change just the
material because I don't want this to be
a wireframe anymore I can open the
inspector again click on the object go
to material and say wireframe no and
then go back up and say copy a trip
notes that was the wrong one copy
attributes and put just the attributes
in here so basically I couldn't go like
no I don't want this I want
oops ah the problem with this is
basically like copies he had an entire
thing which is a bit of a bug but ok
let's let's not get into that yes that
yeah exactly like copying everything is
usually not the best idea because it has
exactly this problem because under the
hood so this is an interesting thing for
performance reasons under the hood job a
frame uses objects in the attributes so
it overrides the set up tribute and get
a tribute methods but obviously the Dom
only supports like strings so it has to
like wrap between the two so sometimes
this leads to a bit of confusion between
what the Dom needs to see and what FMC's
but normally that's not a big of bigger
not a bigger problem but like I'm
actually materials like the worst thing
because it has so many objects in its
properties anyway
cool so now we have like our two objects
here and we have we know how to like
copy it to and from but it's kind of
boring is like we have about how many
primitives do we have we have like 10 12
maybe I don't know see like one actually
let's start from from the top actually
one two
three four five six yeah I don't know
it doesn't scroll anymore that's nice
it's like maybe like twelve or something
like that or maybe twenty who knows but
it's not that terribly exciting so let's
let add some more interesting things for
instance if you wanna have a background
color because right now this is white
because the page is white and if we
would go into the page with obser that
was the wrong keyboard combination ctrl
shift well whatever I thought ah give me
my freaking dev tools come on if I would
go to the body and give it a background
color of let's say background green then
this is this is not nice this is
actually convenient for AR because
basically the scene is transparent so it
takes whatever color is behind it so if
we would have to have a an AR
application we would take the camera
picture and just put it in the
background
but this is not quite what we want right
I don't want the page behind to dictate
what I'm gonna see so what we do instead
is we create a new entity sky
and I think there's I think sky blue is
supported let's see if it is no it's not
grayed out no bigger and I'm doing this
mistake I keep making this mistake it's
a material color sky blue and I think
sky blue support it should be well you
know what I'm actually not sure that I'm
not using the sky that often so there's
actually a thing that I try to not show
you but let's let's do it anyways
there's usually a direct variation of
these components that isn't used like
this so you can do a sky as well and
then you can do actually like sky blue
and I'm pretty sure that I'm should be
getting the sky blue background yes now
I do so you can do that and what it does
is it puts a really really really large
sphere around us a gigantic sphere like
the sky would be a sphere around the
earth which is obviously not true but
you know there's like Hollow Earth
people that think that's the true thing
but let's not talk about them too much
so we can't give this as a color and
that's nice so yes that's a good start
but we can also put an image onto this
now it might not make sense to put any
image because what we really want to do
is we want to put a 360-degree image so
let me actually I have a I might have to
take a turn on the lights again I have a
little 360 degree camera with me
that is the Ricoh theta s and I hope
that it's charged because I charged it
yesterday but I'm never sure if there if
the outlet because my adapters a little
wonky and you know long story short is
[ __ ] so let's turn on the light ah Java
has had a hot cache and it's pretty good
so this thing requires me to connect my
phone to this particular Wi-Fi that its
Bonnie don't get me started and here we
go and I can take the app connected no
internet no really my phone my camera
does not have internet how die is it so
let's see it's gonna look like super
weird because my hands are gonna look
like gigantic probably but it's gonna be
fine
so say jeez that was it
it's super exciting isn't it so I get a
360-degree picture from us which is nice
transferring then I have to upload it to
the cloud to download it to my computer
share it with everyone because that's
how technology works in 2018
isn't it exciting so let's let's connect
to the actual Wi-Fi that we want to use
here shangri-la come on well no don't
forget the Wi-Fi connect to the Wi-Fi
you bastard and ok seems to be connected
does the thing do the thing that I
wanted to do let's see if it's uploaded
in my photos already
let's go up yeah yeah has already
uploaded to the cloud that's amazing so
I'll quickly go to my other browser and
go to photos I hope that I don't have
any incriminating photos anywhere near
here and here we have like this gigantic
image and I'm gonna download it and show
you how it looks like by itself so this
is the this is how the image looks like
and it looks a bit weird you see like
it's like stretched here and it's like
stretched there my hand looks like I
have the an arm of like ten meters
length or something so yeah let's let's
put that on glitch which is where's my
other window here so I can upload it and
then I can share the link with you all
we get computer and this is the image
that I just took it's gonna be a super
long URL so what I'm gonna do is listen
carefully now because I had so many
problems with what's gonna happen in a
second what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
put the link in a link shortener however
that link shortener does not work as a
source for the texture so what you want
to do is you want to click on the short
link that I'm gonna share with you take
the long URL and copy that into your
iframes scene again if you use the short
URL into in your AFM scene it's not
gonna work I'm just gonna use it so that
we have a better experience and using
the gigantic URL that this is gonna give
me unless you want to type that out so
let's go to like I don't know I'll you
know goo dog cos I don't think they need
a root registration I'm not a robot go
away good thank you
here we go so this is the URL that you
want to want to copy over I may actually
you know that so this is the one you do
not put that into your iframe scene you
click on that link or put that link into
your address bar and you get the longer
version back and the long link is what
we need the long URL is what you want to
copy very important
yes sure I'm sorry yes of course I can
do that
there we go
all right all done everyone got the
terrible long URL that we are looking
for wonderful
so the terrible long URL and I'm just
gonna check if it actually does yeah it
automatically replaces with the long URL
so what we do is I don't need that
anymore because I want to be back in my
HTML so instead of saying color what we
can do is we can give it a source SRC
like an image would get a source and we
can copy in or paste in that long URL
and then so basically a sky source SRC
equals and then this long URL we're
gonna get this and we can turn around
and hi everyone how are y'all doing
yeah I can't wave back in VR just yet
bar all right so yes and you can do that
with pretty much any of these pictures
these pictures are called a Cree
rectangular pictures because basically
what you're doing is you take a
360-degree sphere and you unroll that on
to basically you take like you have to
imagine like wrapping a balloon in a
piece of paper and then rolling that
down to like this the plain piece of
paper again
so as this the sky is a gigantic sphere
and this picture was a gigantic sphere
it lines up perfectly it's just we just
have to put it on as a texture and it
looks like the right thing and by the
way if you were wondering like this is a
VR workshop why are we not doing VR why
are we typing things into our computer
and looking at our computer the reason
for that is a it's really hard to get
enough devices like we have a few to try
out in them in a moment but also it's
like super inconvenient to debug most of
the times because you have to put it
into like a USB and then you have to get
like the remote debugger working and all
that kind of stuff and then you're like
oh [ __ ] it's not looking right so it is
it is better than we'd like unity or on
on any of these because you don't have
to like compile anything beforehand but
it's still like a little an easy and the
good thing is a frame is responsive so
you see like this this is a button down
here but I don't have a VR headset right
now right so if I click that it just
goes into full screen mode nice if I
would have a device that has a like a
phone if I would have a haven't done it
on the phone it would automatically
figure out like oh I can do VR with this
and basically I show you an actual VR
picture and use the actual device
orientation to look around so like it is
responsive to the device that you're on
so basically all you're seeing here in
non VR you can try out later in VR with
no additional magic and that's the
beauty of it right and it only works on
like HTC vive if it works on
Kilis rift it works on cardboard it
works on gear VR it works on daydream it
works on Windows mixed reality headsets
not the hololens though i'm working on
that with microsoft it's gonna be an
interesting journey so yeah basically
all the other VR headsets that are out
there on the market do support or most
of them support web PR and a frame just
works with them without having to do
like any magic so basically we are
settled when we got 3d right on the
screen we have done for VR as well and
we're gonna explore that in a bit like I
have a few headsets here that you can
try with your phones okay right so this
this is nice as well so cool yeah we
have a 360-degree picture but you see
like if I'm if I'm now I'm moving around
with WASD but it doesn't look like I'm
moving around and that's because the sky
is gigantic right so like you see that
I'm actually moving around but the
picture in the background does not move
and the reason for that is that the sky
is like I don't even know how large it
is probably like 10,000 meters or
something or maybe a thousand meters and
in size so if you think about it if you
would be walking on a field and it's
like a tree a kilometer away and you
walk toward it it's not gonna be like oh
my god the tree is gonna move so much
because that's the parallax that we get
in our perception that things that are
farther away
I'm not moving as much as things that
are closer by so that's why this is
actually like motion is working in it
but you're not really seeing it because
the sky is so huge but you know let's
let's try some more interesting 3d
objects so how can we get 3d objects
well you have to be coming through the
artists no just kidding you should you
should though because it's like a super
interesting experience and I can highly
recommend it and it's not as hard as it
looks to be honest it's like it's not
too complicated but we're gonna do it
easier we're gonna get our scripts back
so I suggest that actually no you know
what we're gonna start with the first
script first so this is like a shameless
plug because this is what the company I
work for archaeologic builds this thing
where it's a platform that we build for
you to build VR AR and 3d applications
for architecture
and interior design and what we are
trying to do is make your life easier
and we started our journey with an
experiment and we're going to show you
in a second what that experiment is
going to look like so here's my scene
nothing has changed nothing new has
appeared except what happens if I open
the inspector do you notice a difference
probably not because it's like super
subtle because we're not like marketing
dicks so up here in the sidebar there's
a new button that hasn't been there
before it's the 3d dot IO button and we
did that to make your life a little
easier so what I can do is I can click
on it and I get this wonderful little
menu here and AHA this is interesting
there's a bunch of stuff one of them
being poly Google calm so Google has
built a few applications and that allow
you to create 3d content really easily
in VR boom one of them is tilt brush
actually tilt brush costs money now so
I'm not that happy about it but um it's
like twenty dollars or something but
it's really worth it because basically
what it is it's like paint but in 3d
space so you get like a brush and then
you can just say I like painting and you
can paint with fire and water and stuff
I mean you can paint with fire at home
once maybe but in VR it's a lot safer so
that's like nice and then you can export
that to like their platform which is
called poly and there's also another
thing that's called Google blocks and
it's like basic like you NVR when you
have a bunch of primitive shapes like
spheres and boxes and basically what if
a fem has its primitives as well and you
just like put them here and then you
drag them up and then you remove bits
and pieces and then you color them in
and hey you have a car or a house or
whatever so we can like look for
something like horse so this is stuff
that people create it Wow okay this is
underwhelming let's try three okay
better but still not good and here we're
actually gonna see like one of the
biggest problems with these objects so
if we click on this tree for instance
I'm taking like the first one that I get
here tree by and I'm
unfortunate whoops okay hi projector how
are you doing I'm clicking on the first
tree that I got and it's gonna say like
loading and it's gonna load and hey
here's a tree do you see the tree it is
tiny as [ __ ] and and that's exactly my
problem with this kind of stuffs like
where's my okay I have like this is a
tree come on
and it gets better so I'm not blaming
the author the problem is like 3d
modeling is actually hard and we see why
it's hard here so first things first you
might see a weird what the hell is going
on with the protector you might want to
see you might see a thing that it's like
a little odd which is like I'm here on
the object but the the cursor is here ha
what the heck has happened so now I
might go like oh this is not a problem
I can make the tree larger so let's
let's try scaling up the tree so let's
say like 2 2 2 double the size hmm did
that actually scale it up I don't think
so
let's try like 4 4 4 what the hell is
going on okay now it's not actually
because I'm scaling the light okay that
was fun so that's like okay still we
have a bit of a problem here because you
see like the cursor is not where the
action am I am I am i killing the
projector with like it too high of a
resolution or something let's let's
scale to whatever it says it has
hopefully that's gonna fix the graphics
problems okay anyway um so yeah you see
the cursor is not where the actual three
years and if I now start scaling it up
just watch just watch where the thing is
- to - good pie tree has been a fun ride
by and why is that like what the hell is
happening is there's a problem with a
frame no the problem how this is so
weird to have yourself in the background
okay whatever no this is not a problem
coming from a frame this is actually a
problem with the 3d models and
unfortunately a lot of 3d artists don't
know this either so a lot of 3d artists
come from a background where you are
making it look nice when you
render an image so they're like yeah and
I have this object here it looks perfect
from my camera and they're all it's
great and I just put it on the internet
and people can download it and then have
fun with it but there's a few things
that they don't know they simply don't
know because no one tells them and we
are actually fixing that right now by
having like a guide for a 3d artist
student to not make these mistakes and
one of them is the origin of the 3d
program should be the orange like the
middle of your object if you're not
doing that then you have the the
weirdest problems just imagine it like
this let me let me show you something so
if I take this water bottle and I model
it in a 3d program then I have a
coordinate system in the 3d program and
I have a coordinate system in a frame
for instance so we could start with like
if I'm now let's say I'm a smart 3d
artist and I put my zero zero zero it's
right in the middle of the bottle right
right in the middle I can't actually I
put my finger actually I can't put my
finger in its right it's right here oh
that was inappropriate anyway so like my
ball is right here so now if I if I
rotate it I'm gonna rotate it around
this point and everything will be
exactly as I expected but what happens
if my zero zero zero is here and my
bottle is here what do you think happens
that's the right gesture so I'm still
rotating around this point but now my
bottle in my scene goes way and you're
like no that was no that was not exactly
what I wanted to do and scaling has the
same problem when you've scaled all the
math is wrong and then it scales like in
a different direction you're like no
this should not have happened so it
should always be like in the middle
where at zero zero zero in your 3d
editing program and you should also take
care of the scaling poly and paint brush
tip brush and what's the other thing
called blocks do not give you a hint on
the scale so the problem is like 3d
programs use units and units mean
whatever you think they mean now 99% of
the people on the world say one unit is
one meter because it's an easier system
to work with than like inches and feet
and stuff but some people just don't
care
because when you render something I'm
actually going to show you something
real quick
I just wanted because I basically just
recently learned 3d modeling from a
co-worker of mine and I made all the
mistakes myself so I can show you what's
what's wrong with people making 3d
models and it's not like I'm not blaming
them because the tools are just not
helping so let's say I want to create
something this is blender this is one of
the 3d editing software's but you don't
have to install it I just wanted to show
you something real quick so I can create
a cube core now can you tell me how
large this cube is one by one by one
whatever that's correct and the thing is
like I don't even I unlike blender is a
magical tool of wonder that can do all
the things and the interface is really
powerful because you can do things like
this and I'm like what so it's like it's
actually it's not that hard to work with
blender surprisingly even though it
might look like that it's actually not
that that dangerous or tricky to work
with it is actually kind of nice but the
problem is you have no indication of
what the units are so you have to like
in the somewhere in the settings is
actually well hidden and I'm honestly
I'm not sure if I'm gonna find it today
so let's see yeah so hi pretty good you
[Laughter]
think they brought some in back there
somewhere yeah we also have whenever he
allows you to do that you can join us at
the hack attack I'm not holding you
hostage just FYI
coffee there which is really nice and we
have a cocktail robot there cocktail a
little next to our coats and it wasn't
one of them are on Twitter and Facebook
so if you're not following us yet is
calm patience dangle and get the QR code
hold it in front of the robots and it
will make you a cocktail mocktails for
now I think so that is about it would
you mind standing there and I take a
picture oh damn it all of this all this
really exactly you missed our 360-degree
picture it's like freaking photo ops
thank you
yeah yeah like seriously I'm not holding
you hostage so if you you know want to
have a coffee go ahead as I'm kind of
like digressing anyways so yeah you see
like the problem is if I would do this
and I might even like like put it
somewhere here and then move my camera
somewhere and then like start rendering
it like this and I'm like ya know this
looks good this is exactly how I want it
but if I then export this to to a 3d
file then it's all wrong because you can
you can tell if I go to the top level
view that if I would now rotate it in a
frame this being my zero zero zero it
would like do this entire like bananas
crazy movement around a Sun that doesn't
exist and and that's like really really
hard to get right so yet bear that in
mind when you download things from the
Internet's learn at least the minimum
blender you need to actually fix models
so like let's say like I'm actually
gonna show you this just real quick
because it's not that hard so let's say
we we downloaded this wonderful model
and it's not in the right position what
you definitely want to do is you want to
put your camera on the top and probably
disable perspective so that's a little
easier and then you can use G like grab
and then move it to the center like this
obviously that's not always that easy
there's actually better way actually I
made a video with a co-worker of mine
I'm probably gonna share the link on my
tour
account later on because we explain this
in much much more detail and then you
would go like to the front and you see
that gets too far up so I actually got
now gonna gonna move it down and now
this is this is nicer to work with for
artists or sorry for for programmers but
anyway that's a video that explains it
now that I think about it let's ignore
that but basically what we want to do is
we want to have like models that have
the right scale so we don't have to
scale them up we have the right rotation
so we don't have to rotate them that
much and that are centered around the
origins that we don't have these weird
behaviors so Polly is not the best
source for this unfortunately and now by
the way we're doing a little trick here
so you see like all the objects in the
scene are on the left hand side so we
can click the little trash can icon and
off we go
goodbye a little tree not that easily it
is possible it's just like a lot of
gymnastics and it is just easier to fix
it and it's not worth it we also have
like other things in in in our wonderful
little plugin so here we have the
furniture library and the staff picks
staff pics are basically we have a
service and it's it's for free actually
we have a service that allows you to to
get a 3d model from the floor plan
obviously we're not going to show
everyone's floor plans here but we have
like a few 3d modes that we created for
instance like the Big Bang Theory
apartment and you can just drag and drop
it in and boom here you have it and if I
now go back to the scene I am standing
in okay this is weird let's go inside
whoops where am i right now
oh there's a gigantic thing in here yeah
talk about scale right hi so this is
this is to scale this is Sheldon's spot
and stuff like that so this is scaled
correctly and it is normally aligned to
the axes and it is nice to work with and
then you can just just drag-and-drop
things in and export them like the other
things let me actually remove like some
of my stuff here because it's like super
annoying let's get rid of the sky as
well and let's get rid of the
- goodbye box so what we can do then is
we can click here you can click on the
little duplicate here to make it appear
more than once or what it can also do is
over here on the right hand side outside
of what the projector shows so it's
amazing
let's see pop so we can copy this again
copy go into our editor go away go into
our editor I'm gonna remove the sky here
as well and I'm gonna remove these two
primitives as well and then if I paste
this I get like Gupta I get the a entity
and now if we are coming back here then
we are back in the in the apartment
of Big Bang Theory that same thing works
with the furniture library so if you
only need a single piece of furniture so
let me remove this gigantic pieces of
architecture and just like load one
piece of furniture let's say like I
wonder so far I can select so far and I
like this sofa a lot so I'm gonna pick
it and these are actually real furniture
pieces and you can tell like that the
scale makes sense we could sit down on
this one and if I put like I don't know
do we have plants I don't I don't know
I've never tried this let's see what
happens ha we do have plants that's nice
a little greenery and you see that you
like the bounding box fits correctly and
the the cursors at the right position
and I can just like drag-and-drop things
next to it and they look like they are
reasonably sized if you think about it
so far this like little palm tree why
would you put like such a tree in or
whatever like this looks reasonable and
you can import them really easily into
your a-frame scene so that's nice but
you can do other things so like what I
like to do is like 3d free 3d model
gives you a bunch of 3d warehouses they
are called sometimes you can also paint
it like please please please if you see
a nice 2d model just pay the artist it's
worth it
mm-hm but there's a bunch of free stuff
available as well but what you want to
do is consider performance performance
is always a bit of a problem when you
have lots of objects so you want to
probably try the low poly things if
possible and like how do I put this
depending on what you want to do as a 3d
artist you can take a different amount
of triangles for the same object let's
say I get a chair a chair is not that
complicated normally and you can do a
lot of things with like ticks there'd be
like tricks that 3d artists might use to
make it look really nice so you can use
let's say a thousand triangles for share
chair or you can use a hundred thousand
triangles for chair and if you consider
like two hundred thousand triangles
being like the maximum that is
reasonable to put in a scene like into
your entire world then a chair with one
thousand one hundred thousand triangles
is like half of everything you've got
for your entire world that's not
necessarily a good idea so you want to
try to find like the polygon account to
be as minimal as like as low as possible
while it's still looking great and low
polygons does not necessarily mean that
it looks terrible for instance this this
horse is actually relatively low on
polygons but it looks pretty great
how many polygons this will actually
have let's see polygons four thousand
two hundred so that's like not too bad
it's not too great either but it's not
too bad either so you want to find the
ones that are actually making sense or
you create your own ones that's also a
possibility nothing's impossible kill so
we can do that and we can like use a
bunch of these models and we can combine
them as well so let me go back to the
staff pics there's a model there
particularly like which is this one's
like called the style house it's famous
building I think in LA maybe I should
not put it where like the couch is now
in the pool so I might want to
reconsider that
so we can go in here and I can remove
these ones because you know the plants
are nice but if they are standing in the
pool I don't know I don't feel confident
about that and I can now go and and copy
that one into our a frame scene as well
so I'm gonna remove the original one
that I put in and put in the straw house
instead let's do that and here we go
now we have the star house maybe put
like sky around again so that we have a
nicer looking surrounding so I do like a
sky color sky blue yeah it's looking a
little better not exactly sure why we're
not oh because it's one of the things
where we do like a look into so this one
does not have a have a roof okay well
it's a bit weird to not have a roof but
let's let's not go just have to detail
right now and we can walk on the water
that's also nice
so importing 3d models is not as
complicated but what if you don't want
to use one of our 3d models well that is
absolutely fine in which case you
probably want to want to import a 3d
model let me actually see so glitch is a
bit particular about paths which is not
making it easier but I'm gonna quickly
do something for you so imagine that I
find a blender file online which I
conveniently did because it's the exact
same model what I can then do is I can
take this and import export it into a
format that makes sense and to be honest
there's like a lot of different 3d
formats and I highly recommend you to
use what is called the gltf format I'm
gonna explain a little bit why that
matters in a second so let's know
actually I do want to export all this I
do not want to export the camera I do
not want to export animations because
we're not having any missions in here so
let me export this into gltf yeah
bless you so gltf is tracing is just
like a format for 3d data it's like the
JPEG
egg for 3d if you want it's a format
specifically optimized for using on the
web and I'm gonna show you what other
formats exist so like one of them one of
the other very popular formats is obj
obj is like a super old format that is
basically supported by every 3d software
in the market so you oftentimes find
OBJ's but they have a huge disadvantage
now let's have a look so this is this is
one of these obj files let's have a look
inside how it looks like aha so this
file is actually a text file basically
and if we look at it closely and I'm
gonna zoom in a lot if my browser still
like okay blenders in the background
still exporting so that's gonna eat up a
lot of power so we see like a lot of
numbers here you have any idea what
these numbers might mean correct those
are points in 3d
you're oftentimes not calling them
points you're calling them vertices and
three vertices usually form one triangle
which is also called a face so here we
have like lots of coins and lots more
points and even more points and blah
blah blah and then down there somewhere
you have like VT those are texture
coordinates I'm gonna explain that in a
little later or UV coordinates called
them as well depends a little bit and
then we have like faces which are
connecting these points to triangles and
then you know maybe we have groups and
stuff so you see like it's a really
really long file and that's for 787
polygons 102 triangles it has three
thousand lines and it has a size of it
has the size somewhere doesn't it no it
does not show the size where does it
show does it do it here because some way
github shows the size right it's a few
megabytes actually yeah now actually no
it's not that large so this one is
relatively small it's like 86 kilobyte
but it's 86 kilobytes for a hundred
triangles that's not very good right
and there's like no material information
here that's in a second file
it's the MTL file and that looks more
less like this you have like a material
with a bunch of like color numbers here
and then it references the images it's
like you have to do a lot of text
parsing and you have to get all this
text over the wire so it's not very
efficient right because if you think
about this let's think about the data
that is in here for a second so we
basically have a bunch of points in here
and they are like three comma values so
comma values are usually a floating
point values are usually saved as 32-bit
values so the 32-bit is four bytes so we
have three of them X Y and that so we
have 3 x 4 byte makes 12 bytes for one
coordinate for one vertex right but if
you look at it here each of these
characters is a byte so they're like 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 so this much
space is what it would normally take to
store one of these coordinates so we are
wasting a lot of space and even worse
we're wasting a lot of processing power
because we have to read this line by
line break it up into smaller bits and
then parse that into floats and then put
that into the memory for the for the 3d
engine to pick it up it's like a lot of
CPU power needed to actually parse this
into a 3d model and you can imagine that
on mobile doing that with like a 2
megabyte file of this format is not
gonna be great so that's why there's
other formats available like G ot F
which is adjacent based file format but
it can also be binary and then it like
saves a lot of space so that's actually
you know what let's let's up export this
into obj as well just to get a
comparison so I'm gonna export this into
obj and we're gonna do that export
da-da-da-da-da okay and now let's have a
look at the files this is not the right
folder this is the right folder so here
we have like the G RTF file a complete
completely including everything all the
images is quite large is 150 megabytes
the obj is like 16 megabytes but what
happens if I'm not including all the
Cheerios all the files let's see there
must be in where is it actually here
here it is style house Jay G RTF let's
have a look get info so this one is like
400 kilobytes 448 kilobytes versus 16
point 2 megabytes hmm and I can get that
as a single file version which is nice
it's quite large but it contains all the
images and the reason why I did that is
because unfortunately glitch is not
making it easy to upload things that are
referencing other things because
normally what you would do is you would
use browser caching so you would have
like a gif file referencing all the
images because then if like the model
changes and one image changes you would
only download that one image and the
JSON file just like 400 kilobytes and
you would not download all the the
textures again but unfortunately glitch
has a problem with like linking to other
things so we only have to upload one
file to make that work and that
unfortunately means that I'm in the
wrong folder here I believe it's not the
right folder yes that looks like the
right folder let's see how that goes
we're uploading 150 megabytes that's
gonna be whoo okay no damn that looks
more like this oh look at that it's half
done
how did that work yeah I never mind oh
boy I think it's time for a coffee break
but basically how we how we can use
these gltf files oh Jesus
this is gonna be painful conveniently
it's like the same thing a frame comes
with a can actually yes I can that's
lovely
comes to the component for gltf models
so what we can do is we can say like a
entity gltf model and then just give it
a URL to the gltf model so now we don't
have it but so I'm basically gonna be
like to be found out dot yeah so
basically we put in the g-- RTF file
name here and then it loads the geo TF
automatically it's actually faster than
I would have expected that's pretty good
and then we would basically get the same
model so it's a bit of pointless but you
can use gltf models like this it's nice
okay now we have 3d models in here and
we have experimented a little bit but
let's let's do something more
interesting that's add something that is
moving and you know something more
interesting into this so let's say I do
my geometry primitive box material
oops ah color red and I position nope
nope nope nope position it to 0-2
when I'm removing this as well because
we don't really need that oh do I have
the URL now that's convenient let's
let's try if that works gltf model and
right I honestly have never tried what
happens when you export it as a single
file so I'm looking forward to find out
what happens when you export it as a
single file that's what I thought
it doesn't complain so it's probably
still loading it
who knows let's try that out yeah that
might take a while and that's precisely
why you don't do single this is an
important lesson learned by the way like
do not use the single file option
because it's just like not worth it
as it like blocks the rendering until it
actually comes back from the network ok
I'll leave that in though actually no I
won't because I'm gonna use it anyway
but this is basically how you would do
it you would take the URL and put it
into the thing and then you'll be good
why is this thing coming back the entire
time so let me move this down here and
let me move this down here so what it's
unhygienic model so that's gonna start
rendering once it has everything in then
it would basically render as they are
arriving from the network so if you have
like smaller models that's exactly it's
like basically what happens is if you if
you would not have the single file
version of the smaller it would download
the tiny Jason and then discover all the
different bits and pieces and it will
discover like the the binary file files
for all the vertices and faces and it
will discover the images and start
downloading them in parallel and
basically once it has everything that it
needs to render it would start rendering
and we in red renders other entities as
well and in the background so it's not
like blocking everything it's just like
obviously if you have too many to
actually download at the same time
because you have this like download
limit off I think like 16 connections
per host then that would start blocking
but without that it wouldn't ok so what
we haven't done so far is we haven't
done what's called hierarchies
so what we can do is we can actually
conveniently put things inside of other
things so let's do like n/a entity
actually make the outside primitive a
sphere and the color yellow and then
inside here we do like geometry
primitive box well this is a bit [ __ ] no
let's test this fear come on material
color blue now and actually probably
also what's what's gonna be interesting
is like we can do like scale observe
scale and they've got like 0.25 so 25%
of the original scale and now we only
see like our gigantic well not gigantic
but I love our yellow blob here or
yellow blob where's our blue blob well
it's inside because it's the same
position so what we can do here is as
you can see like this is now nested this
is a child of the other thing we can
address it in the editor in the
inspector like this so here you see like
there's an entity but now you have a
tiny little blob on the side to it so if
I press on that you see that last I can
hand it to you hidden inside oh my god
and I can move it out and hey look at
that
hi there's a little thing here so now we
have I don't know Sun and the planet
nice what's worth mentioning is that
they are now hierarchically connected so
the Sun is the parent of the little
actually let's let's get them ID so that
we can easily spot them later on
so ID earth so if I now say I want to
position them somewhere else and I'm
gonna do that in a second I'm just gonna
clean up the code here a little bit as
well so it's a little easier to read on
the projector so if I now say oops
position say like three zero zero you
wouldn't be able to tell that this is
like not the global position this is a
relative position to this one but what
happens if I'm now moving
the Sun maybe let's say like I move it
to like minus five and maybe like 1.6 so
that's on a level and look at that our
little planet has moved with it so the
position of this little planet is no
longer like in world coordinates it's
now in coordinates
real relative to the Sun so basically
what I'm saying is my son is somewhere
let's say like my son is that like I
don't know so let's say this is 0 0 0
and my son is that like 0 0 minus 1 and
now if I say the little son the little
earth which is like my child will be at
0 0 0 it's gonna be where I am and if I
move it's gonna be moving with me
because it's attached to me right so if
I say like can this please move one
meter into there oh sorry yeah into the
screen like minus 1 then it's gonna be
behind me because it's going always from
where I am and not like in world
coordinates this is convenient for an
interesting reason because we can do
things like this we can use this to
create an animation and we're gonna do
this not inside the earth because then
it's gonna spin the earth but we're
gonna do it inside the Sun so on the
same level as the earth we're gonna do
like a animation and I have to look up
the syntax for this because I for the
life of me I can't remember the syntax
because I think it's like prop or is it
actually it's out to attribute okay cool
that's what I needed to know so the
animation tag is using its parent it's
direct parent to change a property over
time or an attribute over time so I have
to tell it which attribute I want to
change and I can for instance say I want
to change the position and now if I say
we started at say like minus 2 then I
can say actually it doesn't really
matter let's say like we started 0 and
then say like I want to start from and
it takes the value that makes sense in
the context so in this case this is a
position so we need to give it three
numbers so I said like I want to start
- 2 11.6 - 5 woopsy 2 - 1 point 6 - 5 so
it's gonna move from the left to right
and I think it's like they're not like
actual de-rate right yes sir so we give
it a duration for the time that this
motion should take and I would say like
5 seconds those 5,000 milliseconds and
and if we reload you see that it does a
motion
hurrah and it does it exactly once now
there's a bunch of properties that I can
set for instance I can set repeat
indefinitely I think I can never tell
it's like English not being my first
language I'm having a hard time actually
spelling that right to be honest yes all
right so if you do like repeat
indefinitely it's gonna keep repeating
that animation the problem now is that
you can see that it doesn't do what you
might want it to have it do like it
doesn't actually bounce between the two
it just basically restarts the energy in
the animation after like five seconds
it's like we flip hey this is not not
quite what we want so there is a few
attributes down here and this is like
the nice thing everything that a frame
comes with is really really well
documented and you have like lots of
documentation available and if you find
something that is unclear you can edit
the page or go to view source or go to
get up and actually suggest that there
should be in a fixed being made so this
is nice and here's a direction property
that you can set to alternate so we do
that so actually let me let me redo the
the way that we do these attributes so
that's a little easier yes
yeah well yeah that's a tricky one so
there is a frame itself has an animation
component but there is a better one that
I don't go into because we would have to
use an external component and I would
like to show you the a-frame bits and
pieces first but it like it does say and
I would have actually mentioned that
there is an external component done by
Kevin go that is having more
possibilities because this is a limited
component so for more cool stuff you can
actually check out the a-frame animation
component and they have like more things
and they're a little little well well
ahead of the actual thing unfortunately
and they have things like you can have
timeline to actually coordinate multiple
animations and stuff like that it's just
a little too much for a basic workshop I
would say and then you see like
elasticity they have a way to not round
the values start events pause events if
it should autoplay you can combine
multiple animations all that but we
start with a simple animation so we are
now in the documentation for the for the
built-in animation component but if you
would have more complicated animations I
highly highly recommend not using the
a-frame component but using the external
one as it is more powerful but for the
simple ones this one is perfectly fine
so if we now say direction I'll turn
eight we're getting this alternating
pattern
now this is not quite what a star does
what the Sun does but what we can do is
we can say okay maybe what we want to do
is we want to change the rotation and
we're going to start from zero zero zero
which conveniently it is already so we
don't even need to mention that and we
want to rotate around let's say the yeah
let's say only the y-axis to begin with
like let's start with this and we want
to go 360 degrees 360 degrees and I
don't want the direction to alternate in
this case because that's gonna look
weird and here we are well this is not
quite how a rotation works right this is
gonna be this is gonna be a really
really weird day here why does that
happen well this is because of easing by
default it eases in and out so basically
it becomes faster and slower to the to
the ends and the beginnings so we would
have to fix that and we can do so by
saying easing linear so that's not
actually doing like modification of the
speeds
we so now we have a rotating earth
that's nice but there's a little bit of
a problem actually I want to show you
something real quick and I'm gonna go to
Google Image Search obviously don't do
that for various copyright reasons but
I'm gonna do it anyways some surface
okay that's let's use I don't know let's
use like this one that sounds like a
reasonable thing do you view image copy
image dress so in the materials you
can't just specify like a color but you
can actually also give it a source so I
can say like source and then use an
image source like this and it's not
working because probably this is an HTTP
no this is an HTTP URL so what is the
problem oh is that one of the cases
where so the syntax has recently gotten
a little inconclusive let's put it that
way because depending on the know what's
the problem here that's it oh [ __ ] it's
a ah cross-origin shizzles come on okay
fine what we're gonna do is like I'm
gonna save this image why do I have to
do this and I'm gonna upload it here to
the assets boom and as that is not such
a large file it should actually upload
it too quickly and here we have it it's
probably gonna look weird because I
don't think it's a proper proper equal
rectangular image but it's gonna be fine
so cross-origin like seriously come on
don't be like that
people don't cross-origin your things
here we go but now this is not what we
want right it's weird that why would the
Sun rotate the same speed as the as the
earth this is not really what we want to
do and this is where the fact that oh my
god what the friends of project are
doing do you see like the little halo
behind the what the rip this is not a
thing this is the projector nice
okay whatever this is fascinating so if
you remember from the very beginning an
entity is invisible right unless we
attach a component to it that makes it
visible it is invisible so what we can
do is we can change our coat a tiny
little bit what we can do is we can say
hey I would like this entity to maybe
not rotate instead we have like an
invisible child that we put both the
animation and the RG both the animation
and the earth goes in there so I remove
them here and I put them into this
entity and move them in a little bit so
that's easier to spot and I probably
like do it like this is a little easier
to spot where the indentation comes in
so now we have the Sun and as child of
the Sun we have an invisible entity and
the invisible entity has an animation
and the earth is relative to this
particular
invisible entity and now we have this
effect and it's not a performance
problem because an entity that has
nothing to render does not render
anything so it's not having any overhead
really it's a tiny little JavaScript
instance in the rendering list but it's
not actually rendered so you don't have
to worry about like performance problems
with invisible entities regarding
performance I also wanted to highlight
something else that is a pitfall that a
lot of people get really really confused
with so what happens if I put the earth
exactly around where the camera is at
the beginning that's already the Sun so
now this is confusing right why am I not
seeing this I'm in the middle of the Sun
but I'm not seeing anything and the
reason for that is a performance
optimization that is usually done which
is it assumes that if you have an object
90% of the times so if I have this
object here it doesn't make sense to
render anything inside that is not
visible from the outside so basically it
tries to be clever and goes like this
part here I actually don't have to
render it because it's hidden you
and see it so why would I render it so
the problem with that is that it's it's
not necessarily like smart about if
you're inside of the things so this is
not rendering because the material is by
default not rendering the insides we can
fix that and if you look into the know
that's the camera I don't know what the
camera I want the Sun if you look at the
material component you see something
where it says side and it has front so
this is like the outside of something we
can as well render the inside and then
here we are in the middle of the Sun
which is probably not a good spot to be
in but yeah so now it's rendering the
inside but the fun thing is if I now go
outside of the Sun it looks a bit weird
right because it's now only rendering
the insides or not the outsides so this
is probably not what we want what we
want instead might be that we want to
render both sides so this has a
performance impact because you're always
rendering both sides but it's sometimes
the only thing that actually helps so
you might have things like let's say a
building with a window and you want to
see through the window into the building
and then the insides would not render if
they would not be set up correctly we
actually our models do that
because we assume that only the insides
of the walls are not something you want
to render so basically was that our in
doors are actually facing in the right
direction so it actually renders
correctly automatically but yeah that's
a that's the thing that you have to
figure out also transparency is
supported you have to like set the
transparent flag and then the opacity to
like 0.5 for instance and then we have
like a half transparent Sun sometimes
that looks a bit weird and funky and
this is in this case because we're
rendering double sided and it like
doesn't know which side is the actual
thing that it wants to render so you
want to avoid having double side
renderings with most of the transparent
objects because it just doesn't know
which side it is showing whereas it's
like giving this weird effect
okay any questions so far could you just
stop at the code I can
anything not working anyone wondering
about the thing I'm trying to get to the
animation how would you suggest
debugging like an animation oh that's
that's a tricky one look at the code and
see like so you have the animation at
this like yeah so did it work in the
beginning or did it like never ever work
ah right okay fair enough so what you
want to do is like the animation always
animates the object that it is like its
parent so in this case we have like the
a entity is an invisible thing but it
has two children it has the animation
and the this the earth and the earth has
an offset so like the earth because it's
just a blue blob if you would rotate it
you wouldn't see it so you would have to
move it off the origin as I explained
earlier with the 3d models I move this
thing so basically let's have a look at
this I move this thing to the right
three meters off the origin of the
actual entity right so we have this
invisible entity here I move the earth
to the side and I have the animation as
a child as well and the animation is
turning the invisible entity and because
this thing is off the origin it was like
there so this is what should happen the
next step would be to check the
attributes because I think and sometimes
they are not very obvious like attribute
rotation okay I get you that pa'dar it's
like not the most obvious thing and
repeat indefinitely for me as a
non-native English speaker it's also
pretty hard to spell right to be honest
and if all of that is right then I would
wonder why it's not working should I
have a look describe the structure it
should be an a seem like website just
the base would be a scene and empty
entity
and then inside of it are two entities
in managed me up one since okay I'm
gonna be on the outside like probably
like the simplest thing you could build
something like this so let's let's start
with a like an a entity that is
basically empty and inside you have
another a entity that is positioned
slightly off let's say like three meters
to the right and you have to give it
something that it's makes it visible so
like primitive sphere material material
color red so let's do that let's put it
here and let's put this here and then on
the same level of indentation so in the
same in the external like in the
surrounding entity not in the entity
that is the little sphere that we just
created you do like a animation and
attribute rotation to 0 360 0 door 3000
maybe it's like the smallest thing you
can probably do and then you should have
oh it's not it's not moving that's great
it's because it actually might have
moved it's just like it has moved 3
seconds long and that might actually
have been passed already
so let's actually give it like the
repeat
sorry but it would no no yeah this is
this is where it's configure where I
find it confusing when I learned this
this stuff is it it is a solid sphere
that is correct but it's not rotating
around itself because and let me repeat
that again look at look at the structure
real clear so basically yes the
animation is going to its parent right
so actually I can I can like collapse it
the collapsing is not really helping
much is this yeah so basically this this
would rotate this invisible entity and
the sphere is slightly off the origin
that should actually rotate it around me
and it does we I love the blur on the
projector like the best thing ever you
describe from here if you want now like
so now I have like the smaller sphere
spinning just around the camera well if
you make that center point now move out
to where the other spheres what I then
do this where's the other sphere
actually is right okay it's right where
we are so that's let's say like s minus
five I move this top-level entity where
the other thing is or so that's one one
way of doing it so the basically I would
have to like figure out is like 0 1 or 6
minus 5 and I might want to actually
move this somewhere else let's say like
I move this to 5 maybe because I don't
want to have them like rotate on the
same it has the easing ok I give you
that it's like still doing like the
weird easing thing but basically now
this this does the thing but this has
the downside of if I now move the Sun
down here right as I say like minus 5
then the Sun and the earth has moved but
this one thing has moved right so if I
want to make that follow what I would do
is I would take the entire thing that's
let's call this like I like to call them
anchors because they're kind of like
invisible anchors right so I call this
the anchor and then I use the entire
block here and I would move that into
the same entity as the Sun or actually
make it a child of the Sun that work
as well so I would make the entire
anchor a child of the Sun and then the
anchor would not have to actually be
positioned of the Sun because I wanted
to be like the same point as where the
Sun is so I can do that and now I have
like the whoops okay now I have the
effect that this is moving with the Sun
so if I move the Sun back to zero on the
x axis the red thing still rotates
around the Sun so you have to be like it
actually I really really really love the
inspector for this because you get like
this tree structure nicer here right so
now we see like the Sun has two children
one is the anchor for the blue little
planet and one is the anchor for the red
little planet and then you have like the
entity of the Red Planet is a child of
this entity of the anchor and then they
have the same setup here for the earth
as you get this like hierarchical
relationship adds to it yes correct that
is correct
if you have these these hierarchies then
the positions are always like relative
to its to its parent and that actually
is true for all of them right that I
mean the sky has a position that is
relative to the scene this is always
relative to the parent and if you share
the parent then you share the offsets
you can either take the entity that is
the parent to the animation and put that
inside of the entity of the bigger
planet yeah or you can have them be two
separate entities and just position them
yes correct
with the downs like the second one with
the downside that if I move the thing
then the other thing does not
automatically move with it right if it's
like exactly you have to then figure
that one out so basically you can use
invisible entities to group items and
then make sure that they stick together
which is actually what happens under the
hood when you load 3d models because a
lot of 3d models are actually made from
individual smaller bits and pieces that
you can address individually and you
don't see that because it's normally not
exposed to you but basically it's
exactly the same thing like you have one
container entity that is invisible and
then all the small let's say you have a
robot right and you have like the two
arms of the robot and the two legs of
the robot and the head of the robot but
you don't want to have to like say like
I'm now moving the head and the leg and
the other leg to the same new position
but you want to kind of have this all go
in one one place so basically what the
loader does is it creates an empty
entity that holds everything the entire
robot and it only gives you the robot
but then internally the animations bits
and pieces actually address the
individual arms and stuff so yeah
and yeah sometimes it's like super
convenient to actually have access to
this kind of stuff
so let's use any other questions by the
way anything unclear as again let me
repeat what I said earlier on one second
this is for you so if something's
unclear
I screwed up and I really really love to
have your question and and figure out a
how to better explain it next time and
be make this work for you
yes very good question so actually we
haven't touched that topic yet but it is
I wonder if they have it here yes so as
you can see like the the camera that
gets inserted into the into the document
automatically and we can do our own if
we want it has not only like a bunch of
properties itself but it also has two
components the look controls and the
WASD controls look how blue controls are
the the mouse dragging around or if
you're in VR your head motion so the
loop controls are what makes the camera
move with your head if you are using one
of the VR headsets and the WASD controls
are literally like moving around in
space or if you have a headset like the
HTC vive for the oculus rift that also
tracks position in the room then it also
lets you literally walk around in the
room automatically so and if you want to
fly that is a setting for the WASD
controls where you literally just have
to say like I want to fly so there's
like a little checkbox here I mean move
zoom in a little bit
so you have in the WASD controls you
have a fly parameter that's the camera
entity so I selected the camera here and
it does not yes and now if I'm looking
up and use W then you see that I'm
flying up over the so it now actually
doesn't it no longer restricts my
movement to the to the to the ground
plane but it actually lets me move
whatever be aware that this does not
work in
we are for the obvious reasons that if
you are like having the position data
from the HTC vive it's gonna use that
it's not gonna let you fly yes it is
possible to do that it's just like you
would have to probably use a different
way of controlling things and you can I
think I've never done that but it's
definitely possible with the influences
with the cardboard the cardboard you
don't have position data so you can just
like move the user where they look for
instance and then that would work
probably also there's an interesting
thing if you are if you're using the URL
that glitch gives you on your phone
you're going to see something
interesting because the the loop
controls that are automatically used let
me go to like four units
- tendency it's interesting one tendency
a glitch da me you get what's called the
magic window function which can be like
super nice or can be super terrible
because if you are then like turning
around in the room you're actually
turning the camera and that's what the
loop controls do automatically so I can
show you why that is not necessarily the
best thing ever
like it's super cool but it's not always
what you want so if I now load it takes
this as zero and basically it shows you
actually my screen is like super dark I
should probably crank up this okay right
you see you see the Sun here right
everyone sees it and I can now like move
my phone that's cool but now imagine
that I'm I don't know I'm walking
somewhere now I'm sitting down in the
Train like this
I see nothing and I have to actually
like move my head around or reload the
page this it's not always what you want
but it's kind of like an interesting
interesting thing it's an interesting
default I would say to start from
and if you don't want that you would
have to remove the the look controls and
find something else that does the right
thing for you our scene
okay is everyone back everyone's seeing
the people next to them or are we are we
did we lost someone to the to the coffee
back I think there's like two people
missing for the coffee break
bum wait a few more seconds also another
tip that I keep seeing people make a
mistake with so you place a camera I'm
gonna expect that in more detail later
on but basically what you can do is you
can say like I want my own camera and I
can select IAE entity camera and hey
look at that we have a camera first
things first if I do that and reload you
might notice that I can no longer use
the mouse or the keyboard to move around
so if you do that like you lose the
default camera which automatically has
the controls attached to them but also
what some people unfortunately like to
do and this is really unfortunate is
they position the camera somewhere so
let's say like I put the camera to like
I don't know five meter sorry zero zero
five let's say like that and this is
nice for a regular like 3d thing and it
looks okay and great but what do you
think happens if I'm going into VR is it
gonna look like that it's not and the
reason is that if for instance I'm using
an HTC vive I actually have a position
in the room right because the HTC vive
tracks the room so I know where in the
room I am so that's where the camera
will automatically move to and even
worse if I am using a cardboard or a
Google cardboard as it started a dream
or something like that
it's gonna start at me it doesn't have
position data so it starts at zero zero
zero and then that's where the camera
moves so I'll not be where I think I am
and I've seen that a lot of people like
mix that up and basically like when like
oh but my up like my 3d object that I
found on the Internet's and I'm using is
unfortunately not positioning around the
origin so it's like in ten meters over
there and 50 meters over there so I'm
just gonna move my camera there instead
of moving the object around the origin
with the downside that they it looks
great on there on the computer and
they're like yeah this is awesome this
is great let's let's send it out and
then the first person to put it on to
our goggles is like I'm I'm standing in
nowhere and back in there at the horizon
and like fifty meters away from me is
something but I don't know I don't know
how to get there right and that's that's
a problem so you always want to make
sure that the origin position makes
sense which means you might want to move
like your objects and your scenery
around to make it match the origin
position you can't guarantee that but it
is it is more like like the let's let's
face it like the maximum room size I
think that the HTC vive supposes like
6.5 meters so you could theoretically
just move over but not necessarily but
like you can you can for instance try to
figure out the position at start and
then like move things around a little
bit or something like that and actually
I think recently Firefox fixed it and
now you actually always start at zero
zero zero and it just adapts to to where
it should be but I think it wasn't like
that in the beginning it's a reasonable
assumption at zero zero zero is good
point to start with but actually there's
like VR has a lot of interesting
challenges one of them being now cool
you have an HTC vive but a not all your
users are gonna use that some being on
cardboard for instance actually most of
them are probably on cardboard and B
what happens if I have an HTC vive but I
only have like two by two meters which I
think that the minimum is like 1.5
meters by 1.5 meters space and now I
have a 10 meter room how does that work
and the answer to that is this thing
called teleport controls and you can use
the controller to actually a teleport
you somewhere like you point on the
floor and then you teleport there it's
better but then you have the UX problem
that not everyone knows how that works
it's not obvious how this works and yeah
it's like a lot of a lot of work has to
be done so what we experimented with is
um I don't remember the URL so be be
nice with me right now because I'm
basically doing something off script I
love to like do things that
just come to my mind but sometimes it
backfires which is like super annoying
so then an experiment that I did that
works with pretty much everything is you
have this cursor that looks so basically
works where you look at so you look at
this thing unfortunately now the model
is loading and to move I look on the
ground and it should trigger but it's
obviously not triggering because screw
me that's why here we go oh great I
broke it as I said I go off-script this
is like the fun thing ah okay now it's
not broken
nice that's probably an old version that
has like a maximum range or something so
basically you look on the ground and
then you move there you teleport there
or should i teleport it through the
modal so I probably want to teleport
back real quick and then like look at
this thing and it goes whoop and I did
user tests and my sample size is super
small so don't quote me on it my sample
says like 20 people and I test with
people who have never done VR before
with the cardboard and they understood
what they had to do so people understand
this way of navigating as I could so how
can I move over there just look on the
ground oh yeah make sense and actually I
only had to tell like three people that
and the other people just knew what they
had to do magically so this is but again
like 20 the sample size 20 is such
nothing so basically just don't trust me
on that one
but yeah after that it's like a lot of
stuff going on it's gonna be super
interesting and with a R for instance
you don't have that problem because you
are using the real world as a reference
point so moving around is not that much
of an issue and yeah lots of interesting
user experience things going on and the
best moment I had was when when I felt
so bad for like making a bunch of UX
mistakes and one of our projects and
then I went to a conference where they
had someone demoing VR and had like a
room escape game and the user had five
minutes to escape from the room and
pretty much every user that tried it
took like three minutes to figure out
how teleport works and and they were
like super super confused about
everything I guess
how do i this is how I move all right
okay oh all my time is over already
what and I'm like yes it's not just me
so you have teleport control Zyra super
nice but not obvious to people yet we're
gonna see that also by the way how many
how many let's say oculus rifts to use
thing have been sold in 2016 I don't
have the numbers for 2017 unfortunately
like worldwide just a rough ballpark a
million ten million okay less what
hundreds of thousands is around the
right ballpark it's like I think it's
like four hundred thousands or something
HTC vive global sales in 2016 were I
think like five hundred thousand ish
how many card posts do you think have
been sold
and I have a guess in them what like
what ball is it hundred thousands or is
it millions or how many millions do you
think less than 10 has been 82 million
devices in the market and that's only
like the official channels because you
can get like weird knockoff things from
Aliexpress or something like that and
yeah they don't count I think so that's
like it's it's bananas so this is like
the reality or has been at least the
reality of VR in like 2016 beginning of
2017 I still haven't found numbers for
2017 so I'm really really looking
forward to see when the numbers come out
for the four last year because I expect
that to change a little bit but it's
like just just seeing that let me see if
I actually I have slides for tomorrow so
you're gonna get like a super sneak peek
of what you're so totally not supposed
to see right now but I just think the
graphic is just like beautiful I hope
that I have it in this version of the
talk I might have removed it yeah damn
it I don't have it in this one in that
case you see something that no one else
is gonna see I'm gonna go to an older
version of this talk because I'm pretty
sure I had a chart somewhere that was
like super fun to look at because it's
just like bananas where is it ah here we
go
yes no no no no no no don't just jump
ahead of myself
okay here we go so like this is this has
been like the VR market in 2016
right you have like oculus rift HTC vive
playstation we are actually doing pretty
well daydream has just entered the
market that that year so it's like this
is comparing a full year against like
maybe a quarter maximum and then you
have like the gear VR that outsells them
is like 2.2 million units and then you
have like the cart whoops the cardboard
slightly more this is like pretty pretty
impressive I might actually enter these
slides back into my talk for tomorrow
so then at most yeah because there's
older versions of car parts that do not
have a button like they have this
magnetic thing that basically works with
no phone and yes we have one button as
an interaction and obviously the gaze of
the user where the users looking at and
like this is an established pattern of
having a gaze cursor oh yeah absolutely
and it doesn't have position tracking so
it doesn't know where in the space you
are so you can't do like whoa I'm gonna
know look down here that doesn't work it
only has the orientation so it only
looks knows where you look at so that's
like yeah that's the harsh reality so I
mean it's kind of interesting to see
like a lot of people are building
building VR applications specifically
for like one type of hardware and then
it's mostly like the high-end thing it's
like oh yeah we has this amazing demo
for oculus rift on that core what
happens when I open that in my cardboard
right so it's like it's not a frame has
this lovely thing called progressive
controls so they are basically like
upgrading themselves and you get like
more interaction so for instance for
click it figures out oh this is the
thing that doesn't have any controllers
attached to it so I'm just gonna use the
gate so you have a little cursor that
like zooms in on to a point and then
actually it fires a click event on the
object that you have looked at last and
that's like super nice and if you then
have a cursor like yes sorry controller
then it goes like oh there's a
controller that's like super nice and if
it's like a cardboard controller you
only get one thing so I can then
actually point at something and like
press the button and it's a click event
so the rest of the code doesn't care and
then I have two controllers because I
have an oculus rift and I'm like cool
it's nice
whew you basically have like a laser
kind of thing going from the controllers
and you're like okay click and it does a
click event so the rest of the code
still doesn't care I'm not gonna lie
it's not always that easy because some
some interactions are just not easy to
map like for instance when you have some
may edit things if you have two
controllers and you know that then you
can just go like yeah and I'm gonna drag
these out how do you do that on a
cardboard not easy does not naturally
come like immediately obviously but you
can detect what you've got and then
there's like things I saw I made that
mistake a lot of times a lot of times
and I got myself really angry with
myself so that's kind of cool because I
learned something there when I build
something for the HTC vive I was like I
have two controllers I'm gonna make use
of two controllers but they are wireless
controllers so they do have a battery in
them so this one might actually run out
of power and ventually and they do not
always like need to be recharged at the
same time so I went ran into a lot of
situations where I knew the hardware I
would be using but I assume that I have
two controllers when I really only had
one because the other one needed two
recharging so I was like and now I use
this second controller which is and then
you go out and like the entire immersion
is broken so not very good so don't
assume things like number of controllers
or a system that you're on assume
cardboard and then enhance based on that
unless you really really really really
know this the setup that you've got so
for instance I built a demo for google
chrome dev summit where I knew that I
would have like recharged controllers
all the time because it's basically a
short demo and straight back to the
charger and I had an HTC vive so I
actually just optimized for that but
it's not a good idea to do that for that
VR because the promise of APR is it
responsively response to what the
environment you're in and it works
everywhere and if you're not making sure
that it does then you're probably
letting your users down which is not
something that you want to do alright
moving swiftly on any any other
questions anything you're wondering
about anything that's not working No
okay well let's let's go back to the
camera thing that I was talking about
real quick and then we're gonna have a
look at lighting as well
so as I said this weird thing here with
the with the orange lines and the white
line that's our camera and that's nice
because if I'm automatically adds this
for us if we are not doing it so I can
click on the camera in the left hand
side scene graph and then on the right
hand side the the entity pops up and we
have like a bunch of components we have
like a camera component that has the
field of view of 80 degrees we can
change that so let's say like 60 degrees
and we just have a like titer field of
view it doesn't really matter that much
I would just leave it like that we can
specify the user height so if for some
reason we are mostly around people who
have one meter eighty then we just
change it to 1 meter 80 but it also has
added other components so it's not only
in a camera component it's also look
controls and WASD controls and look
controls and WASD controls are
components that make the camera respond
to input so we can move
WASD we can use the WASD keys to move
around and we can use the loop controls
to use the mouse to drag around or in VR
this would then also be be using their
orientation so if I put my phone into
into a VR headset this one does not know
where in the room I am but it knows if
I'm looking in that direction on that
direction so that's what the look
controls do if you disable the loop
controls the user can turn their heads
you can do that but prepare to have a
bucket around because people then
usually vomit it's a bucket full of fun
to do that you can also create your own
camera you don't have to rely on the
camera that FM gives you so let's do
like an an a entity camera here a entity
camera so you're not gonna see a
difference except for the problem that
you can no longer move with WASD or turn
with the mouse or even in VR you would
just like get the straight look and it's
not gonna do anything useful it also
allows you parameter
like the user height that I specified
early on so we can give it like the user
height of 1 meter 60 or 1 meter 80 or
whatever notice here there's an
important bit right there which is I
would always use this instead of because
you can basically do what you could do
and you should not do is you could do
like position 0 0 0 1 meter 60 0 right
and it kind of looks the same right
except that if you're now going into VR
you're gonna see something weird happen
and what's gonna happen there is that in
VR it assumes or it tries to get the
actual camera position in what X sorry
in Y direction and also in the other
directions if possible and what happens
if I do it in the cardboard or in a
Google daydream or Google sorry Samsung
gear VR it's gonna set it to 1 meter 60
that's like a same default or whatever
we set in user height that's gonna be
used so if I put my camera on to 1 meter
60 in position it's gonna add 1 meter 60
on top of that so then we have 3 meter
20 tall which is very unusual for humans
for most humans at least it's gonna be
an interesting experience but unless
that's what you want that's gonna be
weird and also if you have the actual
height it is kind of nice to to be
actually like as tall as you are within
the real life so oculus and HTC actually
give you this information so you should
use it and use ur height takes that into
account position does not right so you
don't want to do that you want to leave
it where it is you can also put
obviously you can position it anywhere
else like I can do like 0 0 - actually
you know 10 just plus 10 so you go
really really far away but I said that
earlier on but I'm gonna repeat it for
people grabbing a coffee in the meantime
if you do that the problem is that once
you start VR you are actually at 0 0 0
with the camera or even like in the room
if you move around the room
we are gear supports that so what's
gonna happen is it's gonna not look like
you expect it to look like so what you
should be doing is you should be keeping
the camera at zero zero zero and assume
that that's like the reasonable thing so
we can leave this out actually we can
also do animations with the camera so
let's do that let's just for shits and
giggles a animation attribute rotation
to zero 360 zero duration five seconds
and now our camera turns we if your
users using the are goggles and that
yeah that's that's where vomiting
happens so don't do that don't move the
camera you can do that as long as you
know that you're not in VR and you can
check that you can actually I would have
to check I'm relatively sure that it's
on the a scene actually there is a
property somewhere I don't know but this
it's in the docs that's that's check the
docs because this is actually important
to know my brains not working that well
when it comes to remembering things so I
need documentation for everything it has
it sends you events that's for sure and
I'm pretty sure it also has a it has a
component that actually gives you the
information but this is the wrong thing
it does definitely have a property
somewhere but you could listen for
events as well I'd enter VR and exit VR
gives you definitely this information
that you need
isn't it giving us alright so you want
to listen to these events to figure that
one out we do that for camera tours
because it's just like it's not a good
pattern to never in VR never you move
the users point of view unless they
expect it to move so if you have like a
rollercoaster ride it is fine because
you have a reference point that moves do
not just move the camera around move an
object around the user be it like a
carriage or a train coach or whatever
like anything an elevator is fine as
well just never ever just move the user
without the user willingly doing that
and that starts with things like
teleporting is always already a like a
gray area cool now if we want to get
back like the look controls and WASD
controls we just add them like this SD
controls so now it's basically the back
to the original functionality so I can
look around with a mouse and with
keyboard I moved and on the VR headset
like these that we have here we would
still be able to like look around but we
wouldn't be able to move actually
because it doesn't have position
information these people as are these
headsets do not have position
information unfortunately we can also
control some of the parameters so for
instance you might have noticed that
when we have the WASD controls we are
always moving on the same plane so we're
not actually moving up or down and this
entire like user height missing actually
makes me nervous so that just like
editing so now we can only move like
forward and backward and left and right
we can't move up or down like we can't
fly around what we can do in the WASD
controls it has a fly property or
attribute that allows us to basically
change that and if we look up and use W
then we're actually flying up if we look
down and use W we fly down and stuff
like that so now we have like flying
controls that does not mean that in VR
you can fly unfortunately you would have
to implement that yourself I don't think
there's anything that doesn't
automatically
okay
remove some of the things here so
there's also lighting coming into play
here as I said like 3GS AB nothing a
frame automatically adds lights so we
don't have to which is nice but maybe we
want to have different lighting
conditions so what we can do is we can
do like a entity / a entity and then we
give it a light how do we do that well
that's a component for that so we do
like light now we have to figure out
what type of light we want and one of
the easiest types is the ambient light
ambient light is basically like daylight
it doesn't come from a certain direction
it's just like all around us and it
shouldn't be too bright because it's
gonna apply to all the things all the
faces all the objects in our scene so
what we can do is like we can give it a
color let's say blue now this is really
really dark blue so that's not the best
idea I had so let's actually give it a
slightly brighter I don't know yeah it's
actually not a good not not a bad idea
let's let's try this eye on so now you
see something curious it's actually not
that easy to spot on on the projector
maybe if I go closer no it's actually
really really hard to see but on your
screen the Sun is now like greenish and
that's because the the blue well
actually this is see on lights mixes
with the color of the sun's we like so
we have like this orange color and see
on mixing into this like weird greenish
color if I would instead of using this
this particular image if I would use a
color as a plane color let's say like
come on I use color white then the Sun
is no it's actually not white it's
actually using the light color
right
and you also see something else if I
move around the Sun as I as I mentioned
earlier the problem with the ambient
light is it doesn't have any direction
it's just everywhere and that's usually
a good idea but you should never like to
use super bright colors if you need an
ambient light that gives you some colors
probably use like a dark ish gray and
then use other lights on top of it by
the way if you want like a night scene
you can also abuse this by actually
looks like putting a black light in so
this is now a night scene because it
doesn't actually have anything that's
like driving it so what if I don't use
that if I use it like a darker blue I
say actually still like too bright let's
use like a super dark blue yeah so now
we have like a light scene and you don't
see anything that's not not very
interesting right
so what we probably want to do is we
want to want to use more interesting
lights let's let's start with a point
light let's start with a point light
that we position we don't have any
positioning here so that where the
camera is below the camera actually but
it's like where we are and we give it a
color let's say see on just because we
had light that early on I shouldn't use
like the the hash type point and then we
see that now we actually do have like a
light bulb that is below the camera that
lights straight onto our well son if you
want to call it a Sun actually let's
let's make the Sun yellow again just you
know now the see on color shines on the
yellow sphere making it green it's
probably not exactly what we want so we
can make this white and then it looks
like what we would expect
that's an interesting one not an ambien
like that you could put a point light
into the Sun so what I can do is I can
take this make it a child of the Sun and
it's not quite what you would expect
probably we're gonna see that in a
second so this is not what you expect
right no and what the reason why this is
is because we have a problem so how how
does lighting actually work let me let
me quickly it's gonna be in the this is
one this is one of my favorite
explanations because it's actually
pretty simple but it's it's not obvious
so how do we calculate light well let's
have a have an example here we have a
light source there and we have a surface
here right and now obviously I have it
like black but technically this is like
fully bright as bright as the projectors
makes it based on the light coming from
the projector hitting this fully frontal
now what does fully from so mean well if
you think about it this surface here is
facing in that direction and the light
coming in faces in that direction
there's a hundred eighty degrees between
the two so it's like full-on it's a
hundred percent light of the light that
comes from that direction hits this
surface now what would happen if I would
start to move the surface like this
right now it's no longer the same now we
have a different angle now we have like
the light coming this way the surface
facing this way so we have 45 degrees so
we only have like half of the light
actually hitting it if you think about
it it's like half of the lights kind of
like goes bonk and go somewhere else and
then only half of the light actually
comes back to our eyes if I would like
lift it up entirely yeah then I can't
actually do that far but basically if I
would lift it up to 90 degrees so that
his face is this way and the light comes
from here the surface is not being
affected by the light at all now how do
we model this in computers because we
can't actually like you know shoot light
rays and then see what happens in the
real world and then somehow like map
that know what we have to do is we have
to figure this one out differently and
what you can do is it's relatively easy
to figure out based on their geometry
it's not too hard to figure out where
some
things facing the direction something is
facing is called the normal vector right
so if we if we go into our coordinate
system X being like this Y being like
this and zette being like this the light
has a vector of minus one and like zero
zero because it doesn't go to the left
or to the right to up or down so
basically zero zero and then minus one
because it goes in this direction the
length of the vector doesn't matter so
we're just gonna set the length to one
we normalize the vector that's what's it
called and then we have the normal
vector from the surface going the exact
opposite way this is like zero zero one
so now what we can do is we can figure
out from the textbooks or Google how to
actually calculate the angle between the
two and then we have the angle so we
would know okay 100 degrees and we want
a hundred percent of the light if we
have 90 degrees we want zero percent of
the lights and if we have 45 degrees we
want fifty percent of the light how do
we model this in an equation hmm if you
do a bit of trigonometry and look at
like circles and Pythagoras and all that
kind of stuff eventually or if you just
Google for it that's an alternative to
this a function that with an angle of
180 degrees is 1 and with an angle of 90
degrees is 0 happens to be cosine so
this is how lighting works in computer
graphics you're not doing like any
magical sorcery you're just figuring out
my light goes that way my surface faces
that way what's the angle between them
cosine that and we have how much color
we got right so basically we have like
let's say we have a red color here and
the white color here we just multiply
the two with the cosine and then that's
it that's what happens so it's like
cosine of 180 is one called one times
one which is like the bright white light
plus one only for red and then you
basically just get that together and
then you have like a fully Lidz white or
sorry red sphere here and obviously
because the sphere has more faces facing
in the other directions you do that for
each of these faces and then
get the different shades of a color this
is why you get like you know the the ha
come back okay why it's not as bright
here as it is here this is all it does
ish like this is the simplest way of
doing this kind of lighting it's called
Lambert lighting Lambert lighting has a
problem it has multiple problems
actually the first things first when we
do that for for each of the phases if
these phases are very large it's not
going to look as good we can we can
simulate that by going into the
inspector clicking on the sphere and
somewhere here it should have segments
yes so let's set the segments to a
relatively low number and go back so now
you see like we are not having as many
like the shape is not as round anymore
and maybe I should actually stop
rotating it because it's like super
annoying can you maybe not rotate that
be like super cool thank you and I
should have said so here it looks kind
of nice right it looks kind of smooth
actually I'm not never sure how how well
the projector does but if I remember
like if I reduce the number of vertices
and faces then it's not gonna look as
smooth and you see like the lighting
also does not look as nice anymore it's
a little rougher here and it's like not
as nice here and that's because we do it
once per face there's also ways of doing
like more calculations by doing it for
each of the vertices and then like
interpolating between the two so that's
another way of doing it but like this is
the way that Lambert does it and the
other problem is if I want this to make
it like super shiny then I'm not gonna
have and I can actually return actually
let's just reload to the smoother thing
but you see like it's not very shiny
right there's no like nice shiny light
and that's because this this Lambert
equation does not allow that we would
have to make sure that something that is
coming straight on it it's much much
brighter and then quickly stops being as
bright around the same like like angles
so there's different equations and one
of them being the Phong equation that
allows more complicated lighting
situations and conveniently you don't
have to worry about it I just wanted
to let you know that these exists if you
hear like Phong shading that's like
shiny glossy materially materials and
Lambert shading is like silky smooth
materials we can fix that lighting
problem if you want to make this like
more glossy conveniently by just
increasing a value here we don't have to
worry about all this kind of stuff what
we can do is we can say hey can we be
like more mentally and I can like set it
to a value of 1 for instance and then I
gets like super shiny it's probably like
even too shiny because like the
spotlight is like super bright so now
this looks more metally I would say
because it has the spotlight it has this
highlight over here it's kind of look
nicer on your computer screens probably
than on this screen but hey so I can say
like metal Ness Third Point let's say
like 75 it's a 75% metal and then you
get like a nice highlight instead but
now the question was how can we make the
Sun like shine and look nice yes we can
the problem is with the light and
internally it doesn't mean that it
actually lights up the surface because
the surfaces are like the surface of the
Sun goes like this way the light goes
like this way and 0 degrees not gonna be
nice what we want to do instead is we
want to set a different type of color so
what this is actually like miss named a
bit because in computer graphics books
you're gonna find this as the diffuse
color
now what this diffuse color mean diffuse
color is the color that is being
reflected from the surface because
that's how lights were or how material
colors work right if you have a green
car it means that red and blue are
absorbed and green is reflected so
that's basically it diffuse it spreads
the light in different directions is a
reflection is when it comes exactly back
where it came from and diffuses when it
likes like you know goes astray a little
bit so this is the diffuse color if we
want this to shine light or like looks
shiny then we would have to emit light
right because the Sun looks like it
looks because it emits
slight now this is not the same as
having the light there the light that
you put at a point light that we put in
the Sun is lighting up other things it's
not lighting up the Sun because we're
inside the Sun and it doesn't work with
the angles so we have to set the
emissive color as well I can say
actually no no I'm not doing it on the
red sphere that's not a bad not a good
idea abort mission
abandon ship so emissive yellow and look
at that
okay as a tricky one
theoretically hypothetically it should
work when you set up the let's see
actually that's a good question
I know how to do it in blender but I'm
not exactly sure actually we have
textures here they're gonna look weird
but it it proves the point um so I don't
know actually I do have the actual
texture that I want it does well
completely forgot about that we
downloaded this here because of cause
origin shizzles okay so that's like
source this and that's what I thought
so this is this is gonna be tricky
you're probably gonna have to write your
own material to make that work I don't
think it's actually what happens when I
say like can I can I actually do that
never tried it nope it doesn't support
because there's no such thing as an
emissive map so you would probably have
to do this like differently a way to
fake it is to let's see it's nice a way
to fake this and I actually don't know
the the parameters for this again so
we're gonna look them up is to actually
say that it should not it should not
care about like because there's
different way like light in a 3d scene
it's not something that you physically
intrinsically have to have it's
something that you choose to need if you
want that so you can actually tell it to
like ignore lighting it entirely and I
think aha you here we go flat shader is
that the thing that I want standard
material do I get to actually pick a
different material I wonder how do I set
like
I'll try something because I've never
used that property now that I think
about it so let's see what happens
called shader basic I don't know if
that's the right thing no it's not okay
cool I kind of expect that to happen
we're getting somewhere I'm not exactly
sure where we are getting was an
interesting anyways this is the flat
shape because AHA right so a flat shader
it's a bit confusing because the a-frame
uses three j/s under the hood and 3GS
calls at a basic material and the basic
material just ignores light and just use
it as color and here it's like a flat
shader which to me is something
different but okay it whatever so
basically by saying that you want the
shader to be flat rather than the
standard you get a shader that ignores
lighting entirely and just uses the
texture that you give it and which
effectively looks if the texture is
right looks like it's emitting light but
it's actually not emitting light okay so
now we have like this wonderful little
scene with the Sun and the little planet
orbiting and actually let's find a and
an earth texture as well just Y not very
good question not as easy for glowing
you would have to write your own
material and an old shader I think
there's might be an effect for it that's
actually that's actually look for it I
don't I don't know for sure
fear and put it inside to some expected
right hemisphere lights right but it
doesn't have a position the hemisphere
lights shouldn't have a position okay
but are you sure it looks the same on
the on the back of the Sun if you go if
you go around the Sun I'm relatively
sure with the hemisphere light you might
not see because hemisphere lights are
basically working like the natural Sun
would work on the earth so they shine in
one direction
my work but I would be surprised because
it's normally literally meant to like
shine on one side of a thing and not
like all around it I would be surprised
at that work but you know if if you're
right that'd be amazing because that
means I learned something today that's
be cool try going behind the Sun does
the back of the Sun also get lighted
that way
or below the Sun because the hemisphere
light has to like it it literally is a
half a sphere so it has to light from
one direction but I don't see that you
would have to have a second hemisphere
light to actually light from the other
direction as well anyhow and that's
really cool cool yeah so to make it glow
you would have to oh what the hell you
would have to use a component to
actually make that work and I would not
necessarily use that because it will
definitely have a performance impact you
can write your own shaders and they are
probably custom shaders available for
glowing somewhere like when when you use
our 3d models you actually get a
different shader than the three J's or a
frame shatters because we do light maps
differently I mean there's other types
of light as well you don't only have the
the point lights you also have the
hemisphere light you also have the
directive light a directional light
breezes and you can then start to like
experiment with things so for instance
we might want to do something slightly
different I'm actually not gonna remove
all of this but I'm gonna comment it out
so that it doesn't get in our way
um so I'm gonna leave the sky in because
it's a nice half the sky here so I can
have an a entity geometry primitive
plane and I oh god I can never remember
I'm gonna do like this and I'm gonna see
what happens because I can never
remember which way I have to rotate it
to make it look the way
I want to make it look like so I'm gonna
start with this and I'm gonna figure out
the rotation by just like turning it and
see it's negative okay okay enough so
we're gonna rotate this rotation zero no
sorry
- 9000 so we were tailing around the
x-axis and I'm gonna gonna give this one
a width of 100 and the height of our
depth
I think it's depth depth of 100 so now
we have like a plane that is our ground
plane and I'm actually not seeing it and
it might be because I might have done
something that is wrong right it's not
depth in that case it is is it height
that's like super weird yeah okay fair
enough and you see like I didn't give it
a man material yet and immediately three
J's as I keep saying three days Jesus
Christ a frame jumps in and for our
ground so I'm we now have created a
ground plane and for that to like look
like something it just generates the
color and make sure that we are we're
seeing it but I can also give it like a
material I can say I know I want this to
be color
0:08 a zero zero so we have a bit of
that now I can actually make that white
whoops ah [ __ ] make that white node hunt
hashtag white and I can create a light
light and position it somewhere and I'm
just gonna position it actually I don't
have to position it I think I wanted a
different light I want a directional
light and again I can never remember the
parameters so I just gonna check them
out here direction of what kind of
direction does it automatically go to
the example below creates
shining from the upper left at a
45-degree angle where did the star 45 to
all right okay all right yes yes it's
because the directional light is
basically it's not quite like the Sun
actually works but it's basically like
light coming from some direction and
going towards the origin so the position
doesn't actually matter that much and it
except for we need to figure out like
the the difference between where the
light is positioned and the origin is
the direction that the light is gonna
shine in towards so if I say zero one
zero the light is gonna come from the
top and shine to the bottom because this
is our ground and this is our light so
the like this is the the difference
between the light position in the origin
position this is gonna shine in that
direction from the top and I give it a
color oh yeah let's do something way
purvey V let's go ah let's try a a zero
zero a a and then we do a second light
same light except for I do a different
color and I do a different position so
now this lights shining from the bottom
up and to have a magenta light shining
down from from above and another light
shining up and now we put it as an
additional entity in a entity geometry
primitive sphere material color white
oops color white and we positioned that
in front of our camera so that we
actually see it actually maybe I move it
up a little bit as well so that we see
something and hey the 80s called
now that's so much still too much
no way what okay it's like super super
intensive better so like yeah yeah the
80s called they want their models back
and this is how you do cool vaporwave
and you could also now like let me
actually see so I go to images google
calm and I need a grid image that it's
nicely Tyler ball now that's all
[ __ ] I just need oh god damn it
ciao ah this is not what I am looking
for right you know what I'll do myself
because I'm a great graphical artist
this is gonna be fun come on I can't be
bothered to buy Adobe products so I'm
like yea [ __ ] it is and I was like why
would you use [ __ ] and I'm like you know
let me do my thing
I know what I'm doing I actually don't
but you know it's kind of cool anyway so
let's use black and then use white to
create a little bit of oh Jesus Christ
how do I make this grid parent high
level so it's like 256 pixels
it's like 128 so I go like 124 to a
hundred thirty-two she's like no that's
actually pretty tiny but it's gonna be
fine I guess
and then just like drag it like here I'm
gonna share the URL to this particular
beautiful image in a second so you don't
have to do like this complicated image
editing process
so I'm just gonna copy the layer here
and then just actually now actually I
can duplicate the layer and then no I
can't because it's not transfer are
disguised make it transparent put it in
here and then I do like layer rotate
rotate rotate rotate 90 percent car
twice here we go so this is my grid
hurrah
okay cool so export as PNG yeah let's
call it grid I didn't why is it putting
it into documents no don't put it into
documents this is not a document this is
a this is terrible and it's okay I got
this Jesus so we put this into assets
where's like the upload thing there's an
idea from computer I go to downloads I
got a grid above my grid tada and I can
now go to my brain which is this one I
should probably give it an ID so that I
can just easier identify later on and I
can give my ground a different material
where I'm saying like source is this
wonderful your oops
what uploading UL no don't no don't you
do it
Jesus okay great now I have it like five
times I get a URL from the asset and I
put it in here and whoa okay this is
strike gigantic now this is not what I
want it okay let's do like oh I can't
remember I think it's like repeat ten
ten or something like that
what's that yes right okay now we have
we have fully gone vapor vase here we
can make the overall scene a little less
dark by adding another light like a
really really gentle a entity light type
and ian's color six six six six six
yes that looks like enough sixes that's
too bright actually already so let's
let's actually make that darker yeah
still still pretty bright
yeah that's nicer so yeah
hurrah this is the kind of stuff that
you get to create and then like walk
around and and have a lot of fun yes the
ground is a actually let me let me fix
that a little bit so that's not as hard
to read on the projector let's move it
around here then like rotation and then
a material with a certain source and
that should be it yes okay cool so yeah
blah oh no oh [ __ ] is it all lost now it
is probably all us now oh no actually
it's not because no it is all lost no I
I think I think I think it isn't because
it must have been safe because I was
able to actually go to it on my phone so
it was like fortunate something
something if you logged in I think I
don't know I wasn't locked in so that's
like I was a danger stranger danger um
let's see for sure net tendency okay
fortunate tendency glitched on me if
that's still there then we should be
good and it's still there so we should
be good so let's see it's like glitch me
and then like this and I was actually
glitch comm isn't it ah the naming
convention never occurred to me like oh
look at that I I'm not signed in but it
magically figures out that it's me
awesome thank you so much glitch because
that was like not expected to happen
so yeah you have a plane we give it a
certain width and height we rotated
minus 90 degrees around the x-axis so
that it actually faces upwards and then
we give it a material with a given grid
image if you want to use the grid image
I can create a short URL if you want
yeah you know super like I totally have
the guy no not that I totally have the
copyright on that but I'm okay I think I
make it public domain and I won't make
you pay for this like it's part to be
honest the thing is actually better like
I like I like 1% of the of the stock
photos are just like [ __ ] so I think
this is actually better like you know
they're stuck for this way you're like
what the hell
women laughing at salad is one of my
favorite ones like again don't use the
short URL if you use the short URL in
the thing it's very likely to not work
because it does like a redirect instead
of actually giving you the thing and
then that breaks cross-origin sharing I
think
right any questions so far I could
totally do that
anything particular you're missing
if you don't put the weight in a higher
applying who will just extend it gently
no it will be like one my one meter you
can also use scale to scale it up but
that that means that basically you're
like stretching it a lot and that not
necessarily going to look great with
textures
so I kind of prefer that because it
makes clear that a light is a component
on its own that you can attach to pretty
much any entity that you wish to but
technically not much of a difference
there is pitfall here is for certain
entities there are differences for
instance writing a camera is not a good
idea because of the way that the camera
component system interacts with the
scene this is like it's a it's a little
tricky and whoops it's someone Co
editing this right now because I'm not
exactly sure where the color comes from
is someone highlighting can I see is
this someone like oh yeah look at that
hi very nice meeting y'all interesting
[Laughter]
interesting I did not know that glyphs
can do that but it's cool to figure that
one out no source also like I saw a lot
of people got like super confused for
instance when you like a entity and then
people are like color blue and it
doesn't work anymore why does it not
work I'm like well because it's an eye
entity and color is not a component that
it can use by its own it only works when
you use it with a primitive component so
I kind of prefer that style actually to
be honest when I write a frame component
called I usually don't do that but I
find it easier to teach that way because
it's like on consistent and you always
do it like that I mean I made an
exception for the sky because I couldn't
be bothered to actually look up how the
the sky material thing works is it's
just like not really useful in most
cases also by the way we don't we are
not constrained to use like the things
that a theme comes with so there's a
thing called the a-frame component
registry and I'm actually not sure I've
never used it an inspector so I'm gonna
see how that works so we can add things
to the scene in the inspector
so we can say like add a new thing and
this is an entity so it's an empty
nothing thing right it doesn't have
anything attached to it so we can't
really see any of what it has and I'm
actually wondering if I'm able to this
is interesting so it has all the
components that that a frame comes with
but it also have this has this a fan
component registry and in the component
registry you can search for things for
instance I can search for environment
and I find this and it allows me to
basically like get the URL of the
component and I can copy this I should
have actually copied it on the other
thing before and so again like if you
add something you can see all the
components that a frame comes with and
we also actually see like the i/o 3d
components because we have loaded IO 3d
i/o into our scene as well so here we
have all the wonderful a-frame
components and then you have like the a
flame registry next to it and it gives
you an overview of all the different
available components and there's like a
lot of them you see for instance like an
ocean or force graph case control yeah
yeah the other layouts leap hands if you
have a leap motion yeah so that's like
lots of these components available which
is like super nice and I have just
copied one and I'm gonna go here and
after our scripts I'm gonna do like
script this is super confusing whoever
highlighted this thing can you please
unhide it just nice so what again what I
have done is in the FM inspector I
clicked on a frame registry and I looked
for environment and you get this
component here and I think they actually
also have like previews yes so here we
have a preview of the component what it
does how to load it and how to use it
and here it says like it has a bunch of
presets and has a bunch of parameters
and yada yada yada so I just loaded this
JavaScript into
scripts sin2 my documents it's a frame
environment component and now I can use
it in my scene they probably want to
remove my my ground because I'm
relatively sure that the ground actually
also the lights probably because I'm
relatively sure that it's gonna collide
with what the what the component does so
if I'm now going back and reload
oh I magically lost reload capabilities
so I probably want to do like show live
all right so now this component creates
an environment which is like very nice
and as we've seen in the a-frame
inspector even for these components that
are not a frame components built by a
frame themselves but actually built by
built by by the community you get to see
all the parameters in the a frame
inspector so we can now explore and try
things out so for instance we can use a
different preset let's use strong and
then you get like this Trani environment
it's a bit weird but okay I don't like
these weird towers let's find out what
these towers are where are they coming
from mm-hmm ground spikes maybe what
happens when I say like Hills instead
all right okay no that's not the okay
that's not what I want it so I kind of
want to do like spikes is okay ah
dressing towers I don't like towers I
like trees make no sense mushrooms are
like super weird in this case so how
about okay yeah no that's very nice but
not what I want so can I say like
nothing Oh cubes no that looks even
worse let's go with nothing
so you get to like explore different
things like this this environment
component is really nice because you
don't have to do much and you get like a
nice environment if you're not that much
into like cyberpunk key things then what
you can do is you can also try I think
that's like forest somewhere and this
like actually nice forest here we go
forest and I have like a brightly lit
scene so you don't really have to build
your own environments you can use one of
these templates if you really quickly
want to like build something up but I
highly recommend at least like trying to
build your own environments because it's
kind of fun and gives you like more a
better feeling for the thing you were
creating I'd say fortunate tendency
alright okay if we wanted to get that
into into our code we should be able to
just say like copy this and I'm gonna
[ __ ] do you know what I'm gonna I'm
gonna remix this
[Music]
don't you dare don't you dare okay um
so this is actually like dragging in
everything that it generates is what you
see here is there's a bit of an
interesting secret in this one so what
we've seen in the inspector if you look
closely is that this actually generates
a bunch of more entities right so I had
an entity with like an environment
component but it actually generates a
bunch of entities inside and I can
either keep them or I can remove them
and it's gonna regenerate them that's
basically up to me but yeah so your
components could theoretically create
more whoops okay this is not exactly
what I want it more more things inside
so this component is actually slightly
buggy because it should not do it should
figure out that it has children and then
just reuse the children but instead it's
actually generating them on top of each
other okay what the hell I think I'm
just gonna remove everything except for
the for the preset so that's let's just
not have that yeah okay better
by the way if you ever see like weird
things happen let's let's try something
I want to show you something and explain
to you why it happens because that's
some some of the problems that I keep
seeing people having so let's say like
color red so now we have two skies right
we have this sky that is red and we have
this sky that is dark blue and what
happens is and I'm not sure if it's
gonna happen that nodes it's not
violently happening which is nice okay
in that case that's that's not short and
and the thingy and what instead I'm
doing is I'm doing this I'm gonna copy
the sphere and I'm gonna give this a red
meta material ah dang it's not happening
which is nice but it's also not what I
expected I scale this slightly smaller
maybe scale 0.99 0.99 49 because what I
try to show you is if you have two
entities that are overlapping quite
exactly how this is interesting this is
still not happening it's your friends
everyone hmm it's interesting that I
can't demo it when I really really want
it but if I don't want it to happen then
it happens this is like typical what I'm
trying to show you is like z-fighting
but I can actually reproduce the problem
great basically what you want to look
out for is the things are starting to
flicker that's normally when two objects
are kind of like on the same position
and because it's the same position the
rendering engine has to kind of decide
on random which one to draw at the last
one so it's not guaranteed to be drawn
in the same order so basically is that
nice it starts to fight over who's gonna
be drawn first and last and that's the
sides like flicker especially when you
move when you see that it's normally
because two things are in the same
position it can also be a problem in 3d
models when 2d artists are not careful
enough they might actually accidentally
create to face this on top of each other
and then that exactly is what happens
good
one last thing that I'd like to show you
before we try to do something in VR or
give you the time to actually explore we
are a little bit if you're interested is
I want to show you how to write your own
components because surprisingly it's not
that hard it's not like super obvious
but it's not at heart because there's
really really good documentation that
explains it really really well so what
I'm gonna do is I'm first gonna I'm
gonna get our nice nice teen back
because I kind of liked it yeah that's
the thing oh one more phone block one
more thing before I do that there's also
an a text component that gives you the
possibility to actually create text it
works slightly different than you might
want to expect um the text component is
documented in here as well as it's part
of the text I'm sorry a part of the FM
distribution you can use google fonts
and stuff with it if you use it an
additional an additional component for
that and it has like these fonts font
faces built in basically so that that
works as well you can also generate
funds from it I've only always found
that to be like confusing and weird so I
never did it but you can hypothetically
do that and how it works is you position
it as anything else you would position
so let's say like zero to minus two and
then you give it the text asset that is
actually incorrect it's an a entity see
that's what I meant with like being
consistent a entity and you give it the
text component and you give it a value
and in the value you say like hello
world and then where is it it doesn't
show up because I think I've forgot to
give it a material as well to a color
white
do I have to give it a Fontenot Oh
probably our sphere is in the way isn't
it bum - - yeah there it is hi there
there's also an external components of
this this one has one downside it has an
upside as well as performance-wise this
is really nice because it just basically
renders a single face but on the other
hand it doesn't have any depth right and
if you are standing behind it
well alright it's gone um so if you want
to have something more like thick and
and and with a bit of depth then there's
like the 8x geometry which is really
nice but it has the downside of actually
rendering more triangles so it's like a
bit of a you have to figure out what
what makes more sense in this particular
case you can also render two-dimensional
images as well as like an a image
component that actually renders a single
image that floats in space you can also
do that I think I haven't done that yet
but it's not too like too exciting but
if you have like regular images that you
want to have like an image gallery or
something like that then you can do that
by basically saying a entity image and
then you give it like a source and you
can also give it a width actually like I
don't know a JPEG and you give it a
width like 0.5 which is like half a
meter high it's like a 0.25 or whatever
and you position that as well so that's
not like super exciting but I wanted you
to know that this exists it's not only
360 degree images you can also do like
normal 2d images so what I'd like to do
is I'd like to get our I don't need to
defer our script used so if we want to
create a a frame component we do that
using the a frame and is it a frame was
it like a frame I can never remember I
think it's a frame register component
and we give that an object
and I think we also give it a name and
yes we give it a name in an object so
basically I would call this planets I
don't know we would have to figure this
one out
so let's give it like a planets
component and the first thing that we
have to do is we have to figure out our
schema so if you remember we had in the
inspector we had like all these
different properties right that we could
set like the material they had like
color and the geometry had like
primitive our component might have the
same and we want to define it in here so
let's say in our and our planets thing
we might want to give it the number of
planets that our or let's actually call
it solar system that makes more sense
solar system the number of planets and
for the inspector to figure out what
kind of data this is we have to give it
like a bit of help the number is any
number including floating-point numbers
but that makes no sense because we can't
have three point five planets that does
not really work so let's use int which
is just any integer number we can also
give it a default value if it's not
specified it should have the default
value and I say this one and it can be
two it doesn't matter it's just like
that's gonna be the default and we can
have multiple of these we can have I
don't know moving shall have like type
I think it's boolean I'm never sure and
default shall be true so this is how we
define the properties that are our
component will have an ephemeris has two
methods that it's gonna call on this one
is the init function that's gonna be
called initially and it's the update
function that is called and everything
something's changing
oh I forgot a comma here I'm sorry for
that so let's just start like with the
update function and Co like updating
solar systems not very exciting it's not
doing anything interesting just yet
but it does log something to the console
so we can figure out if our component
would be working
so again in the schema we're defining
all the properties that our component
will have and then we have an init
function and an update function to well
create the thing initially and then
afterwards whenever it needs updating we
can update it
here violin typing so I'll wait a moment
so now we're not really using this
component so we want to want to change
our index.html to actually use this
component so let's say like we have an
EI entity and we have a solar system now
if we reload we're not seeing anything
because we haven't created anything yet
right we haven't done anything visible
but in a console it says updating solar
system yay so basically this is the
moment when the component is basically
getting like updated information on what
it should be doing based on the
schematics and if we now go into our
inspector actually let me remove this
and go into the inspector and we select
the entity which should probably be this
one then we see that the properties that
we've given it in the schema appear here
right and I can change them and I can
say for and I can say I don't want them
moving so you see that based on the type
that we've given the the interface
actually updates and it has a few nice
since I've set four but I can also like
drag and then it increases in steps of
one because we said it's an integer
number so it doesn't do like floating
point numbers in this case if you look
at our console again and we see that it
has been called more often now that
we've changed and if I change this again
you know you see like anytime this
information changes it is actually
changing or updating our components it's
calling this function that we have in
our component we can also do that
manually and I'm in not exactly sure if
this is gonna work the way that I want
it to work so let's see like I want all
a entities yes thank you and I want the
one that is I should have given it an
ocean I should have given it a an ID so
that it's easier for me but if this
looks right so components lists all the
components that this particular entity
has and here's our solar system
components so we can go in and say solar
system and now in the solar system
component
we have data and data is exactly what we
enter here right these two match so if I
now type in like five here and I call it
again and we see like number of planets
is now five so you can programmatically
access and change this information not
that you should do that but you can and
then you can also manually like call
update so I can actually go in here and
say like solar system data moving equals
true and I think it was false before and
then we can call update on it and okay
the inspector doesn't update that's an
interesting one but if I now close and
open the inspector again and it's
actually updating the inspector there
must be a leak somewhere cool but this
is not interesting right we haven't
actually rendered anything we haven't
done anything interesting in our in our
component so can you can we do something
interesting here yes we can huh yes so
how about this how about we go in and
say this which is the component get oh
god is it do I get object 3d or is it
get through the object I can never
remember the syntax here let's let's
check is it like get object 3d 3d get
objects
no ah get 3d object okay time to look at
the documentation I'm so sorry but it's
like to be honest everyone reads the
documentation all the time and I'm not
gonna lie to you and going wrong I
learned this by heart no I just we are
not in school here come on set object 2d
and get object 3d so okay it's like with
the uppercase D alright so basically
what we can do is we want to create our
own things and there's two ways of doing
this as I said a frame is wrapping
around three J s
so if you happen to know the three J's
library then you can use that so what we
can do is we can for instance a bar mesh
equals new three mesh so mesh is
basically the exact same concept as an
entity and in a frame it's just then a
different term for it and then if you
like three e-box geometry one one one so
this is like the geometry so here we
have that and then we need a material we
learned that earlier on actually let me
we format that a little bit so that's a
little easier to see is like it's a mesh
basic material and by default that's
gonna be white so that's gonna be okay
and then we close this one and then we
say like this said object 3d mesh and
now our component actually explodes
because this said object okay right ah
is it ah maybe I'm an idiot let's see I
might just be an idiot no I'm not an
idiot
okay cool that gives me this element
said object 3d all right I know it takes
an hour
damn it because it can have multiple of
these we're just gonna get like the mesh
shall be this mesh and then hey look at
that our solar system is now a white box
very exciting I'm dying of happiness
this is this is one way of doing it and
it's definitely the more flexible way
but that means that you have to learn
three jeaious to write your own
components but what if I tell you that's
not true
another way of doing this kind of thing
is by saying look at that we have this
element is actually the HTML element
that we're in so we can append children
to it now how do we create one well as
it's an HTML element so what we can do
is we can say okay I want the son
because we have to have a son with a
solar system we have to have a son come
on
I want the son to be an A Frame element
and a entity so we create an instance of
an of an a entity tag which is what the
Dom does behind the scenes anyways when
we were writing the HTML and then I can
say like sunset attribute let's say I
emissive woopsy oh this is not what I
want it sorry for that emissive yellow
whoops ah what the hell
and then we append the Sun to the
current element you can actually use
that ouch [ __ ] no you're right I'm an
idiot it's a it's the material component
that has like emissive yellow sorry that
was my my bad
very good point very good for pointing
that one out before I'm like what the
hell is going on here
and by the way I kind of want to move
this around a little bit so right now
it's under our camera it's also like not
very nice let's move this around tiny
little bit so that we actually see it in
front of us
aha why is it not doing it
oh because we yeah another thing is
obviously I forgot to set another
component which is since you have the
three components so yeah that was not
very smart
geometry primitive sphere so we're
literally like using the Dom API to
create this for us
and here we are
and then what we could do is we can move
forward so let's let's say like for VAR
i equals 0 is smaller this dot data dot
number of planets i plus plus we're
gonna like VAR planet equals document
create element a entity so this is this
is now starting to get repetitive
hopefully absolutely basically it's
screw this crap I'm like just gonna you
know screw it let's let's do that for
the sake of simplicity we're just gonna
make them all I don't know read it's not
Sun anymore it's planet that was my bad
copy and pasta error and then you said
like Sun appendchild planet also we
probably want to move the planet a
little like somewhere else so we do like
set attribute position I was like let's
go like I times 2 point 5 meters plus
well that's the better in the way now 0
0
yes I'm eating in these initial offset
so we're now moving them a little often
than we are pending the the planet to
the Sun there's a bit of a problem now
that wait where's my planet hmm I do not
get my planet oh it's big ha that's what
you meant with an offset yes I they okay
right yeah that makes sense
two point five plus nine times two point
five so that we do not start with zero
there we go it's quite harsh isn't it so
maybe we want to do like planet planet
setattribute
scales like I know 0.25 sort of looks so
we're going to find 0.5 so that we get
like a smaller planet but basically
that's that's it we would now have to
work out how to deal with this when the
number of planets changes alternatively
we could always like recalculate I mean
the number of planets is probably not
gonna change as often so what we could
do instead is we could say like okay so
the Sun is not never gonna change so we
don't have to do this so what we can do
is so you can say like a set of Sun
actually we can do like that and then
like this Sun equals Sun so that we have
a reference from it and then we take
this off into the update function and
what we can do theoretically is we can
say like this start Sun dot innerhtml
there's definitely better ways of doing
this but like for the sake of simplicity
this is fine
it's like this the Sun because what
should be happening now if I'm not oh
wow
what oh is it calling wait wait wait
wait wait am i doing something stupid
right now because I probably have I
think actually it's wash it it might
actually be my tab died
at night it might actually call it when
we are updating the the children but I'm
not sure it shouldn't actually so let's
see ha now it doesn't now works fine
okay whatever
whoa no this is the wrong nope
still the wrong key hello ah there we go
control our eye so if I now zoom zoom
zoom if I now go in here and I say okay
this thing here shall have three planets
then I'm wondering what's happening oh
there we go three planets surprise
surprise and then we could do like all
the animations and all that basically
the tree can get more complicated then
we could move it if moving is true so
you can build these these components
like that and I prefer it over the
three.js way for most of the things
because it's how components can easily
kind of be composed together to build
more complicated components but then
again if you really need the 3js objects
don't shy away from them it's not as
complicated this is still a really nice
abstraction over the raw WebGL also you
can do things like you can actually
query the children inside of your
component so you can say like if you
want to change the way that the Sun
looks or if you want to give me a
different entity for the Sun then just
give it and i don't know class or
something and then i can just load that
from what you give me instead of
creating myself yeah that's yeah it's
possible there's also a callback in call
components have a callback that is
caught when the children change so you
can even observe that so it's it's a
really flexible system and the Dom makes
this relatively easy to actually build
this anything
yes yes they're all represented in the
Dom there's one exception so as I said
like the a-frame does these
optimizations for the attributes so they
turn it turns the attributes the
different component attributes into
objects which the Dom does not support
right so you have instead of position as
a string 0 0 0 you actually have an
object X Y Z 0 0 0
it doesn't always update the Dom
immediately so if you really really need
to export that to the Dom there's a
function call flush to Dom that you can
call to actually get like the string
versions back into the Dom that's
causing a little bit of a frame rate
rate dropped for us like for half a
second or something whatever but if you
really need to export it that's the way
to go like I've seen people who have
like an editor where you put something
together and then you click a button and
you get like a text field with the HTML
inside and they're like oh it's missing
all my information because it's not
unless this goes like solar system
equals empty string and it's like no
there's information in here like number
of planets should be 5 and it's moving
should be false and you can use flush to
Dom to make that happen like to make it
flush it out as a string to fix that
phone here we've been sitting like the
whole position straight at once just yes
you can do that by using the the
JavaScript method that I used earlier on
so basically what you would do is you
would go like let's let's just do like
pseudocode yeah entity components
position data z equals 5 and then you
would have to yes I know it's not an
actual actual thing you would then have
to call update manually to make sure
that it's actually like reflected in the
component but that's totally possible no
I don't wanna what
no go away so yes it's lunchtime I
already know actually I did not steal
any minutes yet it's like three we have
three more minutes do you have any
questions anything else that I should
cover yeah for example for light just
looking at the a-frame docks it doesn't
describe the types of life are you sure
about that when I went to like the light
it said
it should oh yeah right yeah right yeah
we have like them here listed out in
quite a bit of detail actually the FAA
from documentation is really good
there's a there's a slack for a-frame
you find the links in in the a-frame on
the a-frame site actually so like here's
a community tab that has like the
documentation github Stack Overflow
Stack Overflow is also really really
great too if you have actual questions
but the slack is really really helpful
as well if you have any questions you
get quick help there yeah go to meetup
groups that are doing stuff like that if
you have some some nearby I don't
actually know if there's that many
meetup groups around a frame yet but I
would I would recommend the slack if
there's anything that's not clear in the
documentation because to be honest like
the the project is relatively young it's
in like it's probably like Europe maybe
now or main like one and a half or
whatever there's it's not that old yet
so there is holes here and there but
everyone's like super helpful and making
sure that you understand everything that
it's a few Mozilla people at the back by
the way hi long time no see and like
everyone's like super helpful and if you
find something that's missing all the
documentation some github so you can
literally just add edit the page and
make a pull request and then make it
better for everyone
sorry you're exactly who's staying for
the afternoon afternoon workshop it's a
few people I think so theoretically they
are all full but I highly recommend if
you're really interested in just stay
for the afternoon workshop you might get
a seat if you're lucky just stay around
and see if there's like spots left and
then just you know hang out because it's
gonna be super cool it's gonna be an
advanced workshop and you're gonna do
the the city thing right yes
yeah I mean the reason why I'm super
excited about a frame and why we are
also actually excited about it at 3d i/o
is that it's relatively easy with a few
lines of code to actually build things
like this for instance so we have like
an application that loads this entire
thing and you have like camera tours
that take you to the different rooms
let's go to like bedroom - I don't even
know which one it is
that one okay fair enough and if you
look at the code it's actually not that
complicated so you have a bunch of CSS
okay cool yes sure
and afterwards you have a bit of a bit
of whoops [ __ ] what the hell is Mac know
why is it navigating when I don't want
to navigate and then you have like a
bunch of buttons you have a logo here
which is literally just an image you
have a map which is like the the thing
and then you have the buttons that that
use a frame components you see exactly
what I showed earlier on like component
store it has a go-to method it goes to a
certain bookmark and then it just does
the magic in a frame and the a frame
code itself is hot Jesus Christ my
computer goes bananas
no don't navigate away when I try to
what the heck okay right
the f-m code itself is basically you
have the camera you have the different
tool waypoints and you have like a light
it's and you have here this is the
apartment and that's it right it's like
it starts here and the actual scene is
done here and the rest is just like
specific like like tweaks and nice nice
T's so it's not that much code it's not
that hard to get there and you can
basically build like really really cool
stuff really quickly and it's like super
flexible huh
yes so check out your local communities
check out Meetup and just play around I
think the most important thing is to
just like start playing around with it
you very much enjoy lunch and yeah if
you have any questions I'll be around at
lunch